Gucken wir mal, ob Windows wieder um...
Man weiß es halt ja nie, ne?
Moin.
Oh ja.
Alle zeitgleich am Start.
Wir brauchen mal Package Update.
Schadet nix.
Arch, by the way.
Guck mal, alle hier gleichzeitig
zur gleichen Minute am Start.
Aber nicht zur gleichen Sekunde.
Ich weiß nicht, kann man Sekunden-Timestamps irgendwie haben überhaupt?
Nee.
Seto ist gemutet. Achso, haha.
Okay.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man sich das anzeigen lassen kann.
Hat jemand von euch...
Wobei...
Ich würde es sehen, wenn ihr es habt, oder?
Hat jemand von euch Twitch Turbo...
Aha.
Pepo benutzt heute den Shave Champ.
Oder beziehungsweise
hat jemand von euch schon mal Twitch Turbo ausprobiert?
Weil ich hab mir überlegt...
Eigentlich...
Ich hab's gestern übertrieben, ey.
Gestern drei Stunden Fahrradfahren.
Was ist Twitch Turbo?
Äh, Twitch Turbo...
Das ist ein...
Das ist quasi YouTube Premium für Twitch.
Pricing.
Ja, bla bla bla bla.
Premium.
Die zeigen natürlich nicht an, was es kostet.
Es kostet 11 Dollar, glaube ich, gerade hier aktuell.
Sieht man mal wieder nicht richtig.
Also es ist quasi YouTube Premium für Twitch.
So, und ich hab mir überlegt...
Der Kro... Also...
Warum ich die Leute...
Wenn ich die Leute subscribe bei einem Channel...
Liegt zum größten Teil einmal...
Also, es liegt einmal daran, weil ich das gerne gucke.
Aber zum anderen auch,
weil man das Ganze auf dem Channel, wo man subscribt hat,
by the way,
werbefrei gucken kann.
Auch mit PrimeSub, geht auch.
Kann das werbefrei gucken.
Aber nur diesen Channel, wo man subscribt hat.
Und wenn man Twitch Turbo hat,
ist das komplette Twitch werbefrei.
So, und jetzt ist halt das Ding.
Für zwei PrimeSubs, ungefähr,
oder nicht für zwei PrimeSubs, für zwei Subs,
kriegst du schon, kriegst du quasi auch Twitch Turbo.
Deswegen überlege ich mir,
ob ich nicht einfach Twitch Turbo hole,
nur noch meinen PrimeSub im Monat mal vergebe und gut ist.
Weil letztendlich gucke ich ja relativ viele Channels so random über Twitch.
Und es gibt auch genug Channels, da gucke ich keine Ahnung.
Einmal im Monat rein für eine Stunde oder so.
Da subscribe ich jetzt nicht.
Und dann habe ich überall werbefrei.
Leider funktioniert ja,
youblog, nennma richtig,
auf Twitch.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da nicht irgendwelche
Spezial Plugins,
Bloglisten,
was auch immer gibt für Twitch, bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Man kann das Ganze,
das Ganze bestimmt auch über irgendeinen Streaming-Player
oder so aufmachen, sofern
die das nicht in-Stream encoden.
Aber Twitch Turbo wäre
auf jeden Fall die einfachere Variante.
Und ich hätte die Kohle sogar
einfach easy wieder drinne,
wenn ich meinen zweiten Handy-Vertrag
kündige, den ich gar nicht benutze.
Einfach sinnlos
Geld zum Fenster rausschmeißen aktuell.
VLC, geht
eigentlich VLC noch
gescheit? Weil VLC
mag
mit Twitch ja ab und zu nicht.
Wollen wir es mal ausbringen,
ob VLC noch funktioniert?
Also was mit Sicherheit funktioniert, ist wahrscheinlich
dieser
wie heißt das?
Dieser Streaming
Streamer
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Ding heißt.
Streamer, Streaming-Viewer
oder so.
Da gab es doch irgendwie so ein extra
Tool für. Mal gucken wir mal,
ob VLC das Ganze noch kann.
Nee, also VLC selbst kann es nicht mehr.
Also was geht, ist Stream.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Ah, jetzt habe ich Stream Twitch.
Da gab es doch so ein Stream Link.
Was meine ich?
Stream Link.
So, und jetzt konnte man sagen Stream Link.
Muss man mal gucken.
Stream Link und das Ganze dann nach VLC pipen.
Okay, man kann einfach sagen hier Stream Link Wubblors best.
Und jetzt streamt er das Ganze.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist geil.
Die haben mittlerweile wirklich die Werbung
in Stream.
Zwar nicht die Werbung selbst,
aber die Werbepause ist in Stream.
Sogar wenn man sich
den Stream hier, guck mal, geil, oder?
Detecting Advertise Break
of 15 Seconds.
Also die haben tatsächlich
ein Delay
im Stream, wenn man ihn aufmacht
über externe Streaming Tools.
Weil Werbung,
sonst im Browser abgespielt.
Ja, also selbst das funzt nicht richtig.
Also, und wenn das schon nicht richtig funzt,
habe ich irgendwie den Eindruck,
dass die temporär erst mal gewonnen haben.
Temporär, bis es das Nächste gibt.
Und ich für Twitch Turbo hole.
Mit Twitch Turbo ist dann quasi
für den Preis von zwei Subs
eine ganze Seite
werbefrei.
Und ich gucke random alles Mögliche auf Twitch.
Ja, also ich gucke ganz viel unterschiedlichen Krempel.
Und da will ich nicht alles subscriben.
Ja, ich gebe 1, 2 Channels aktuellen in Sub,
die ich wirklich regelmäßig gucke.
Krabi zum Beispiel gucke ich regelmäßig.
Den Prime sub ich auch immer.
Aber ansonsten, äh, wie heißt das hier?
Gibt es Twitch Turbo?
Ja, das können wir mal gerade gucken.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Wobei ich das dann wahrscheinlich nicht
mit meinem normalen Account machen kann.
Weil da ist ja Standort und so deutsch.
Und da muss man ja nicht sagen,
nicht piercing.
Pricing.
Twitch Turbo Pricing.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
weil ich habe hier ein Land hinterlegt.
Bei mir.
Wo ich wohne.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das machen muss
für den normalen Twitch Account.
Ich glaube nicht.
Aber ich muss es hinterlegen für
meine, äh, wie nennt man das?
Also, wenn du,
Monetarisierung.
Muss ich das hinterlegen.
Stonks, genau.
Ja.
Und,
deswegen wissen die das.
Ist ja egal.
Also, erstmal kurz gucken.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal Indien.
Gibt's da, Moment!
Sind die High IQ und es gibt für
Indien gar kein,
gar kein Twitch Turbo?
Geht dein YouTube über Ausland?
Ich hab lange nicht mehr verlängert.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, Ukraine.
Könnten wir, könnten wir
7 Euro sparen.
In Russland, okay. Wir gucken mal.
Was sind
300 Dings.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Rubel.
Oho, guck mal da.
Ein russischer Prime,
ein russischer Turbo Sub
würde uns bloß 3 Euro kosten.
Also, Norwegen ist gar,
garantiert teuer.
Ah, nee, kostet ungefähr, ist klar, aber.
Okay. Also, Deutschland kostet
12 Euro. Also, wenn man sich
Twitch Turbo über Russland holen würde,
beziehungsweise könnte, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das geht.
Guck mal, Swedish Kokona.
Dann würde man,
würde man tatsächlich
ungefähr 9 Euro
sparen. Weiß halt nicht, ob das
funzt, ne. Warum hab ich eigentlich immer noch
Bootstrap auf? Keck, wait.
Weiß es net.
Moment, stimmt, stand
die Türkei drinne?
6 Dollar. Ja, Lira, versteh ich,
dass sie das nicht nehmen.
Die Währung ist ja richtig am abkacken, gell.
Wobei, ist es nicht so, dass bei Lira
irgendwie laufend irgendwas angepasst wird
und jetzt sogar die Preise im Land
übelst teuer geworden sind? Ich hab da mal
vor einem halben Jahr oder so einen Artikel drüber
gelesen, keine Ahnung,
inwieweit das stimmt.
Zumindest ist das wohl auch ziemlich für den Arsch.
Eigentlich krass, wenn man sich überlegt, gell.
Ich hab gestern mir so überlegt, ey,
so als ich jung war,
so, keine Ahnung, so
18, 19, 20 oder so,
da hab ich mir ab und zu mal überlegt, ey,
fährst du mal irgendwo hin, so in Urlaub
und so nach Ägypten und sonst was?
Hab ich nie großartig gemacht.
Das weiteste, wo ich in Urlaub
gekommen bin, war in die Türkei.
Ich bin kein großer in der Welt rumfahrer,
aber ich hab's mir überlegt, ja. Und ich hab mir
damals so gedacht, ey, wenn du
dir mal so überlegst, du kannst eigentlich
in 60% der Länder auf
der Welt, kannst du eigentlich nicht fahren,
weil's zu unsicher ist, ja.
Südamerika kannst du in viele Ecken nicht fahren,
Afrika kannst du in viele Ecken nicht fahren,
Asien kannst du in viele Ecken nicht fahren, Russland
kannst du eh damals wahrscheinlich auch schon
vergessen. Also konntest du quasi 60%
der Welt, konntest du,
also auch mit angenehmem Klima und allem,
konntest du quasi als ich jung war vergessen hinzufahren.
Und da dachte ich mir so, ey,
weißt du was? In 10 oder 15
Jahren ist das bestimmt alles besser geworden.
Da kann man bestimmt in viel mehr Länder fahren.
Und
heute ist das eigentlich
eher schlimmer. Heute kannst
du in, keine Ahnung, 70% der Welt
nicht mehr fahren, ohne dass es gefährlich ist.
Nach Ägypten würde ich beispielsweise
nicht mehr fahren mittlerweile.
Also insofern, ja, hat
sich nicht zum Positiven
entwickelt.
Ägypt.
Oder generell in der Ecke.
Lange keiner mehr gefragt,
warum ich immer
Sachen paste in mein Terminal.
Also aktuell paste ich eigentlich nur rein, weil es
verlangweilig ist. So, jetzt haben wir alles geupdatet.
Reboot.
Ohne Mist,
Frankfurt ist
auch anders geworden die letzten Jahre über.
Was das angeht.
Auf jeden Fall ist Frankfurt anders geworden.
Frankfurt ist,
ich weiß nicht, ob Frankfurt insgesamt
krimineller geworden ist, das kann ich euch nicht sagen,
keine Ahnung. Ich habe aber den
Eindruck, dass Frankfurt gewalttätiger geworden
ist. Also abstrakte
Kriminalitätsraten in Frankfurt ist eh
so ein Ding, weil da hast du auch ganz viele
Finanzgeschichten und
sowas dabei. Aber ich
habe den Eindruck, Frankfurt ist gewalttätiger geworden.
Die letzten
ja,
zehn Jahre über.
Und es ist auch ganz anderes Klientel in den Straßen
unterwegs. Früher Frankfurt zum
Hauptbahnhof.
Frankfurt und aufmach es Ägypten
nur in modern.
Halb Ägypten ist ja auch mittlerweile da,
zumindest wenn es am Hauptbahnhof langläuft.
Aber das Klientel
hat sich in Frankfurt auch schon richtig, richtig,
also richtig krass verändert. Früher
so vor zehn Jahren bist
du in Frankfurt rumgelaufen,
da hattest du dann irgendwelche Leute,
die hingen im Türrahmen und hatten noch die Spritze
im Arm hängen oder
hingen auf der Treppe rum am
Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof. Das waren hauptsächlich
Drogenabhängige am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Natürlich auch insgesamt saumäßig viele
Assis und sowas. Aber
die siehst du heute
zunehmend weniger Frankfurt
am Hauptbahnhof
beziehungsweise Frankfurter Bahnhofsviertel.
Du hast natürlich auch immer noch gerade so Nidderstraße
und sowas oder auch hinten
das ist auch die Ecke, wo diese
Drogenausgabestelle ist.
Also diese legale Drogenausgabestelle.
Drogenausgabestelle ist ja überall
am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Ja, und
da hast du noch die Leute,
wie sie früher überall im Bahnhofsviertel waren.
Aber um den
Hauptbahnhof rum,
da ist das Klientel anders.
Ich wusste übrigens bis vor einer Woche
nicht, was dieses Wort bedeutet.
Ich habe nachgeguckt, weil das glaube ich
ich habe auf Reddit,
ich weiß bis heute nicht, wie man es ausspricht,
ich habe auf Reddit irgendeinen Post gelesen
von irgendeiner Schule, die gesagt hat,
dieses Wort ist gebannt. Und das hat mich natürlich
interessiert, weil ich wissen wollte, was das ist.
Ja, und ich habe
nachgeguckt, was das ist. Also dieses Wort bedeutet
wohl
ja, junge Ausländer
so mit typischem Look quasi.
So mit Gucci-Klamotten
an und Gangster-Look
und sowas in der Richtung.
Wir werden alt. Ja, ich wusste das
bis vor einer Woche auch nicht. Ich gehe davon aus,
dass das in der Jugendsprache
komplett etabliertes
Standardwort mittlerweile
ist. Naja, zumindest Frankfurt am Hauptbahnhof
ja,
mittlerweile ist das
im Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof hat sich das geändert.
Von den durchschnittlichen Frankfurter Assis
Drogenabhängigen hast du
zu 90 Prozent,
wenn du den Hauptbahnhof langläufst,
also nicht im Hauptbahnhof, im Hauptbahnhof selbst,
einfach durcheinander als Fuck.
Wenn du die Wege um den Hauptbahnhof langläufst,
hast du heute gefühlt nur Afrikaner.
Also ganz viele Schwarze,
90 Prozent Schwarze.
Und du wirst auch laufen von der Seite
sehr offensiv angeschwätzt.
Früher
ist dir das... Das hatte ich mal
ganz weird, Champ, ja.
Früher ist mir mal einer, das ist schon ein paar Jahre
her, ist mir mal einer drei Straßen
hinterhergelaufen, weil er gedacht hat,
ich will Drogen kaufen.
Ich muss da wohl den zu lange angeschaut
haben, als ich über die Ampel gelaufen bin,
in seine Richtung, und das hat er interpretiert
als, Alter, komm mal mit
in eine etwas ruhigere Ecke, ich will
was kaufen.
Der ist mir drei Straßen hinterhergelaufen,
man. Ich hab mir schon gedacht, Alter, was ist hier los, ey,
der verfolgt mich.
So was hast du heute weniger
am Hauptbahnhof, hast du immer noch, hast du weniger
am Hauptbahnhof. Heute hast du, heute wirst du laufen
von der Seite angelabert, wenn du Richtung
Hauptbahnhof läufst. Allerdings mit nix, mit
nix speziellem. Die Leute machen
so komische Geräusche, wenn du da langläufst, so
na, na.
Ist ganz merkwürdig, ey.
Ich fühl mich wirklich nicht wohl am
Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof mehr. Ich hab mich noch nie wohl
gefühlt am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof, aber
aktuell so wenig
wie nie zuvor, ja.
Lauf da auch nicht gerne lang.
Gibt ja immer wieder, ey.
Und wisst ihr, was ich da nicht verstehe? Frankfurt
hat übelst Geld, ne.
Frankfurt ist, glaub ich, eines
der, wie heißt das, weiß
ich auch nicht, reichsten, reichsten Städte,
weiß ich nicht, ob man das sagen kann, Frankfurt muss ja auch viel Geld
ausgeben, aber auf jeden Fall eines der
einkommensstärksten
Städte in Deutschland.
Und Frankfurt hat auch schöne Ecken, so ist das nicht.
Das Bahnhofsviertel
gehört nicht dazu.
Die haben zur WM,
äh, zur EM? Ne, warte mal, was war
EM, ist gewesen.
Zur EM haben die sich richtig Mühe gegeben im
Bahnhofsviertel.
Bekommst du eigentlich Gefahrenzulage?
Es wird langsam mal Zeit, ja.
Es wird langsam echt mal Zeit.
Zur EM haben
die sich Mühe gegeben am Hauptbahnhof
und, äh, drumherum.
Die üblichen Stellen, wo morgens die Leute
reingepisst haben, wurden da teilweise um
6 Uhr schon sauber gemacht.
Und du konntest zum ersten
Mal seit Jahren
zur EM durch Frankfurt
laufen, normal, morgens durch die Straßen.
Du hast Leute gesehen, du hast Abfallautos
gesehen, du hast, ähm,
Stadt, ja, so Stadtmüllabfuhr
Mitarbeiter gesehen, die die Straße sauber
gesprayt haben und abgewaschen
haben und sowas. Das hast du sonst zwar auch
gesehen, aber nicht in dieser Menge. Du konntest
während der oder vor und, äh,
zur EM, konntest du morgens
durch Frankfurt laufen
und es hat nicht gestunken.
Das war schon
nicht schlecht.
Sobald die EM fertig ist,
fertig war, quasi
Stichtag, war wieder alles beim Alten.
Alles wieder versaut, wie vorher.
Hat einfach keiner aufgeräumt.
Also seh, also ich würd
nicht sagen, dass ich, dass ich jetzt Angst hätte
am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof rumzulaufen. So schlimm ist
das nicht. Aber ich guck schon ein
bisschen, ja, mit Sicherheit.
Also, ich hab, also, neben,
neben, ähm, Müllabfuhr und sonst was, hab ich
selten so viel Polizei auch gesehen
im Bahnhofsviertel. Ich mein, die sind da eh schon viel aktiv.
Aber jetzt, also es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich
permanent Angst,
wenn ich, äh, im Bahnhofsviertel
am Hauptbahnhof langlaufe, dass ich gleich irgendwie
ein Messer in den Rippen stecken hab. Wobei,
so unwahrscheinlich, wenn man sich die
News anguckt, gerade aus Frankfurt, ja,
ist das ja auch mal gar nicht.
Also ich hab jetzt nicht permanent Angst, wenn ich am Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof rumlaufe. Wir sind jetzt, wir
sind noch lange nicht in irgendeinem
brasilianischen Slum oder so,
wo der, wo der Typ einfach mal die AK
74U rausholt und
gegen die Wand ballert, wenn er sich aufregt.
Da gab's doch mal dieses Video zur Fußball-WM
in Brasilien. So, Fußballmannschaft hat
verloren. Was war die spontane Reaktion
der Fans, irgendwo in irgendeiner
Slum-Ecke in Brasilien, AK 74
rausholen und wild auf eine Wand ballern?
Das war, das, das war
so das, das war die Standardreaktion, wenn man
sich ärgert. Ah, bam, ich
baller jetzt mal einfach kurz ein Magazin auf die Wand,
jetzt ist es wieder gut. Also so schlimm
ist es Frankfurt am Hauptbahnhof nicht.
Aber sich, also
sicheres Gefühl, wenn man da langläuft und
sich die Leute anguckt drumherum,
hatte man noch nie, aber hat man in letzter
Zeit ganz besonders nicht. Ja gut,
Frankfurt, Frankfurt Autofahren ist eh für'n Arsch.
Kurz abreagieren kennt man
doch. Ja ey, es gibt Leute, die schlagen
auf ihren Monitor,
wenn sie eine negative KD haben.
Und es gibt
Leute, die haben halt die AK an der Wand hängen
in Brasilien und ballern nochmal kurz auf die Wand.
Was willst du machen?
Gehen wir rein in die Black Ops Beta und machen
einen Commentary.
Ich hab die Beta nicht gespielt, ich hab mir
nur ein paar Streams angeguckt, aber
ich hab mir mit dem
Fabian überlegt, wir spielen
mal ein paar Runden, wenn das Game rauskommt.
Vielleicht,
gibt's ja dann ein
random
oldschool Video, so als
wäre die letzten
12 Jahre nichts gewesen.
Ja, das muss ich sagen, finde ich
auch, die Videos, die ich gesehen habe,
ich muss aber auch sagen, das hatte ich das Gefühl,
bei den letzten Call of Duties
auch, ich finde, die Games
sehen seit Modern Warfare 2019,
also ich finde, Modern Warfare 2019
kann man klar erkennen,
dass das das Jahr war, wo das technische
Grundgerüst geändert wurde.
Ja, das Jahr davor noch Black Ops
3 oder so.
Und dann Modern Warfare 2019,
also da hat sich grundlegend sehr viel
geändert und
seitdem fühlt sich quasi
jedes,
das kann sein, dass das Track da schon
daran gearbeitet hat, ja, aber seitdem
fühlt sich
jedes neue Call of Duty
ein bisschen an, wie
auch von der Optik und der Schrift,
wobei Schriftart bin ich mir nicht sicher,
die ersten Teile hatten immer die gleiche Schriftart.
Ja, also sowohl von
vom Feeling her,
vom Movement her,
auch wenn sich ja Movement was geändert hat, aber so
generell die Responsiveness, alles,
alles fühlt sich irgendwie nach
MW
2019 an.
Ich mein, es ist nicht so, als wäre das nicht vorher auch
so gewesen. Im Prinzip kannst du sagen,
jedes Call of Duty
seit Call of Duty 4 fühlte sich an
wie Call of Duty 4
bis halt MW 2019.
Also da war ja wirklich so ganz
ganz kleine Steps immer.
Es ist nicht nur seit
sieben Monaten kein neues Battlefield, es ist seit
sieben Monaten überhaupt kein Video erschienen.
Seit
220 Tagen oder so.
Ja, das stört mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Das fand ich in Battlefield 4 schon ganz cool,
dass die jetzt realistisch gesprintet sind
mit manchen Waffen und nicht so
gehumpelt.
Wie in älteren Shootern noch normal
war. In älteren Shootern,
wenn die Leute da mit der Pistole
gerannt sind, dann sind sie immer gehumpelt.
So.
Ja, Leute, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich heute streamen
kann. Ich hab's gestern ein bisschen übertrieben. Ich bin gestern
drei Stunden Fahrrad gefahren.
Und heute merk ich's echt im Rücken.
Und mir tut auch der Kopf ein bisschen weh.
War einfach ein bisschen
lang und zu holprig.
Ob's jetzt da sinnvoll ist, noch irgendwie
zehn Stunden vorm Rechner zu sitzen, wage ich zu
bezweifeln. Ja, das ist so.
Das ist
der Inbegriff von
Call of Duty
Verkaufsrekorden
der letzten, keine Ahnung,
15 Jahre über.
Es funktioniert halt und
wir kaufen's. Wenn man mal ehrlich ist,
die hatten schon ein paar richtig gute Spiele dabei.
Gerade Call of Duty 4
und Black Ops 1
waren auch
MW2 auch noch ein bisschen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, MW2
hatte mir persönlich schon
zu viel
Randomness und Schnickschnack.
MW2 war quasi so der Umbruch.
Also COD 4 ging noch
klar. COD 5
ging auch noch klar.
Black Ops 1
ging auch gerade noch klar.
Aber ab, beziehungsweise in dem Moment
MW2 war vor
war vor
Black Ops 1. Ja, aber trotzdem
da hat's angefangen. Das war so
der Umbruch. Da gab's, ab da gab's so
super viel Random-Faktor
drinne.
Du hattest früher auch schon in COD 4 Random-Spawns
und Sachen, die dir auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Aber du konntest das noch irgendwie halbwegs predikten,
was passiert. Ab MW2
ging das gar nicht mehr. Und du hattest halt enorm
viel Bullshit drinne, der
im Prinzip auch zwar anders
geworden ist über die nächsten Games, aber
immer weiter drin blieb, ja.
Granatentroppen beim
Sterben, Last Stands,
irgendwelche komischen
Revenge-Spawns,
One-Man-Army und
solche Dinger. Ja, das gab's nicht alles 1 zu 1,
aber es gab immer ab dort
unglaublich viel Bullshit,
was dich Random gekillt hat.
Und deswegen sind die ja auch irgendwann weg von
Wir versuchen
halt gute
Runden auf die Reihe zu kriegen
zu, ja wir machen die Motivation
hauptsächlich durch, ja ab und zu
mal paar ganz coole Momente, Killstreaks
und vor allem Millionen von
Unlocks und Skins und
Prestiges
und Challenges und Passes
und whatever.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass xDefine jetzt 20.000
aktiv... Ist das so?
Ja, xDefine ist gut
gestartet, habe ich danach nichts mehr
von gehört.
Was sagt, was sagt der eigentlich?
xDefine Twitch
Weiß nicht, lass mal gucken.
Ne, habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Äh...
Zuschauer viel wenig?
Konnte man auf Twitch nicht mal
sehen? Ah hier.
Ne.
Konnte man auf Twitch nicht mal sehen?
What the hell? Alter!
Konnte man auf Twitch nicht mal sehen, wie viel Zuschauer
ein Game insgesamt gerade hat?
Ging das nicht mal?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, wo das mittlerweile hin ist?
1.800?
Wo ist das?
Ich sehe das gar nicht. Wo ist das?
Warum ist das so kacke?
Muss ich hier durchsuchen machen?
Und dann
xDefine
Kannst du... Muss ich jetzt hier runter scrollen
oder was, bis ich es gefunden habe?
Okay. Mega,
mega nice Usability.
1.800
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich meine, das ist für ein Game, was
irgendwie jetzt versucht, da oben mitzuspielen, natürlich
nicht der Wahnsinn, aber
das ist ganz
okayer
Twitch, Twitch
Account. Das ist aber, glaube ich, ein Game, wo
Leute nicht gerne zugucken.
Leute, es ist übertrieben warm, Alter.
Ich mach nochmal die Klimaanlage an.
Die letzten Tage so aufgeheizt.
Ja, das liegt wahrscheinlich zum
größten Teil auch an Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Ist meine Ansicht, das Ganze.
Weil du eigentlich immer
nur so
semi-gute Runden hast.
Du hast immer so, ja, geht so.
Ich bin nicht scheiße,
aber geht so Runden.
Spit add'n. Kann ich machen.
Wir haben mehr als, mehr als genug Emotes
frei. Kann das nicht add'n.
Warum nicht? Ich hab keinen add-Knopf
da. Okay, Seite
reloadet, jetzt geht's.
Wie gesagt, ich denke, das liegt
zum größten Teil an Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Hast du Deadlock ausprobiert?
Nee.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht bin ich einfach zu,
zu
selektiv, was Spiele angeht.
Ich hab mir das angeguckt,
und ich fand, das sah erstens super
steril aus,
und zweitens, finde ich, hat die Umgebung
und
die, die
Charakter da drinnen überhaupt nicht
zusammengepasst. Auf der anderen
Seite, was ich gleich wieder nice fand,
dass es
gleich das typische
Source Engine, oder sagen wir mal,
Valve Source Engine Game
like Crosshair hatte.
Weiß ich nicht, in MW2 haben auch die
Noobs weitergespielt.
Es kann, es kann aber schon sein.
Also, da ist, da ist schon, da ist schon
was dran.
Es gibt ja auch heute sehr viel Auswahl, ja.
Du musst dich nicht mit nem Game rumschlagen
und, und, ähm,
ja, zehn Runden in Folge auf den Sack kriegen.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Also, ich hab Streams geguckt,
das sah,
ja, das sah irgendwie okay aus.
So ne Mischung aus
ein bisschen Dota,
mit ein bisschen Overwatch und Team Fortress,
so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das, wie man das beschreiben soll.
Du hast unterschiedliche Helden, du hast allerdings
auch unterschiedliche Fähigkeiten und nen Shop.
Quasi wie in, wie
in Dota. Du hast mehrere Lanes,
du hast, ähm,
Creeps, die man sogar last-hitten kann,
wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab. Da gibt's dann, gibt's
dann so Seelen, die kannst du entweder abschießen oder
im Melee hauen und dann kriegst du die klein.
Und, ja, so ne, so ne Mischung ist das.
Es ist ja eigentlich recht clever von
Valve sowas zu machen, weil
die haben langjährige Erfahrung mit Dota.
Auch wenn sich da
immer, es wird, egal welches Spiel,
ja, egal ob CS
oder ob Dota, im Prinzip macht sich jeder
dort über Valve lustig, immer.
Aber, die Spiele sind
seit Jahrzehnten, na gut,
naja, Dota 2
gibt's bestimmt auch schon über 10 Jahre mittlerweile.
Sind die erfolgreich?
Haben Millionen Spieler
und laufen.
Und, gut,
Team Fortress hat Valve einfach vergessen, die letzten
10 Jahre über haben sie gedacht, ne, hab ich keinen Bock mehr
drauf, äh, Team Fortress 2.
Dass die jetzt sowas machen, so ne Mischung
aus dem, was sich etabliert
hat und was die Spiele haben, die
erfolgreich sind, das wundert mich
jetzt nicht, es ist eigentlich gar nicht verkehrt.
Mit ihrem, wobei man halt auch sagen
muss, Valve hat immer noch einen ziemlich guten
so Track Record mit Spielen, was sie rausgebracht
haben, von Game Releases
zu guten Games.
Das einzige, wo Valve meines Wissens nach
die letzten Jahre, was mir so einfällt, ja,
die letzten Jahre in die,
richtig ins Klo gegriffen hat, war
Artifact?
Architect? Ne, wie hieß das?
Das, das Dota Hearthstone.
Dota Kartengame.
Da haben sie ziemlich ins Klo
gegriffen.
Aber ansonsten
releast Valve ja nicht viele Spiele.
Es, die, die haben ja die letzten
Jahre über, ja, ne Handvoll
vielleicht rausgebracht.
Aber wenn sie was releasen, dann ist das
in der Regel auch gut.
So, hab ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet? Ich glaub schon.
Mal gucken, was es so trendet.
Auf, auf Shithub.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
32 Monate.
Ich warte immer noch auf Half-Life 3.
Es gibt auch Leute, die warten auf Left 4 Dead 3.
Oder auf Portal 3.
Oder, haben die noch, Team Fortress 3.
Haben die noch irgendwas, wo
ne 3 fehlt?
Selbst League hat keine neuen Spieler mehr,
die Zoomer geben dem Spiel keine.
Ist das wirklich so?
Also ich hätte, ich hätte gesagt, League of Legends
ist immer noch so eines der erfolgreichsten Games,
die es gibt.
Ich mein, es ist sicherlich nicht mehr DAS Hype-Game
wie vor 10 Jahren, wo jeder LoL
gespielt hat. Aber ich glaube,
es gibt auch noch die ein oder anderen Zoomer,
die Spiele mit Tiefe suchen.
Die nicht heute das spielen wollen,
morgen das, sondern ein Spiel, wo man quasi erstmal
reinkommen muss und dann halt auch merkt,
dass man besser wird.
Ja, das, das stimmt bei vielen
Games, die älter sind. Da habt ihr schon recht.
Games, die es
seit, sagen wir mal, 8 Jahren oder so
gibt, da hat sich ja 8 Jahre lang auch
was entwickelt. Und die
haben oftmals ja auch neuen Content bekommen,
die letzten 8 Jahre über. Was heißt,
du hast eh schon ursprünglich ein saumäßig
komplexes Spiel gehabt. Heute hast
du alles, was die letzten 8 Jahre dazu
gekommen ist, noch an Komplexität
dabei. Plus,
dass viele Leute, also dass sich vieles schon
etabliert hat.
Was du wissen musst, ja. Machen wir mal
ein Beispiel, ja. Wenn die Leute
früher irgendeinen MOBA angefangen haben,
da sind die da reingejoined, haben sinnloses Zeug
gemacht und im Prinzip haben die meisten
anderen Leute auch sinnloses Zeug gemacht.
Heute musst du teilweise wissen,
wie ist die Timing dieser Creep
Wave zu welchem Tower. Dann musst du
dieses Minion delayen, dass das dann nicht
auf den Turm schießt. Und
ja, und ganz, ganz abgedreht, wie gesagt,
ich bin kein großer MOBA Spieler, ja. Ganz
abgedrehtes Zeug. Und wenn du das nicht weißt,
wirst du quasi schon in deiner ersten
Bronze
Liga Ranked Runde
so geflamed,
dass du wahrscheinlich uninstallst.
Ein anderes Beispiel,
wo es nicht, genau
das, woher wusstest du es, dass ich das
sagen will, genau das wollte ich gerade
sagen. Ein anderes Beispiel
von Games, wo es jetzt nicht um PvP geht,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob Path of Exile überhaupt
eine PvP-Modus hat, zumindest
spielt das keiner, ist
Path of Exile. Path of Exile ist
ein Game, da haben die einfach die
letzten, boah, 10 Jahre, ich weiß nicht
wie lange es das schon gibt, 12, das gibt es ewig.
Ich habe das, als es in der Beta war, mit dem Fabian noch
gespielt. Das muss 2010 oder so gewesen sein.
Was macht eigentlich, by the way, was macht eigentlich
Path of Exile 2
Release Date? Sollte das nicht letztes
Jahr irgendwie zu Weihnachten rauskommen?
Early Access 2024.
Verrät endlich den
Release Termin.
Ah, soll im Early Access
2015 November.
Ja.
Die wollten das vor 3 Jahren eigentlich schon
released haben oder so. Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich beschwere mich da nicht. Wirklich
nicht. Mir ist es so lieber,
wenn das
eine Weile reift und
was Gutes bei rauskommt, als
es wird unfertig und in einem
Kack-Zustand
undurchdacht released. Also es ist mir lieber.
Ja, ist mir lieber.
Das Ding, was Path of Exile ist, jetzt nicht
bei Path of Exile 2, ich denke bei Path of Exile werden
sie viele Sachen angehen, der Sachen, die sich,
die Probleme, die es bei Path of Exile gibt.
Also Path of Exile selbst
ist im Vergleich zu MOBAs
ja ein reines
nicht zwangsläufig Singleplayer
Spiel, das nicht, aber ein reines PvE
Game.
Da gibt es kein Competitive
Multiplayer PvP
Faktor oder sowas.
Das Problem bei PoE ist,
dass sie, ich habe das ja auch
eine ganze Weile gespielt und ich spiele das auch hin
und wieder. Bei den letzten 2 Ligen habe ich nicht gespielt.
Aber ich spiele das auch hin und wieder immer.
Und da sind auch mal ratzfatz 100, 200 Stunden
weg, ehe du dich versehen kannst.
So, das Ding ist, die haben bei Path of
Exile immer
neues Zeug draufgepackt.
Jede Liga
neues Zeug draufgepackt. Also am Anfang haben die
das Spiel ja noch sinnvoll erweitert mit mehreren
Akten, wobei man da
sagen muss, ganz
ehrlich, Chatge,
mal eine Frage
an alle, die PoE gespielt haben.
Kennen den Spiel mit einer dümmeren
Story als Path of Exile?
Ganz
ehrlich, ich
kenne kein Spiel, was eine so
dumme,
unzusammenhängende,
weird, champige Recycle
Story hat, wie Path of Exile.
Also, die Kampagne
ist einfach so unglaublich
kacke. Also, nicht vom
Gameplay her. Vom Gameplay macht das sogar jedes Mal
Spaß, am Anfang von einer
Liga da mal durchzuraschen
durch die, man muss die ja eh machen durch die Kampagne.
Macht Spaß, so ist das nicht. Aber die Story,
die ist so unglaublich
random,
dumm, unzusammenhängend,
recycelt und
noch was.
Mir fällt kein Spiel ein, was so
dumm ist von der Kampagne her,
wie Path of Exile.
Du merkst bei Path of Exile richtig,
dass die angefangen haben mit drei Akten,
dann versucht haben, das
weiterzuführen, keine Ideen
mehr haben, hatten,
irgendwas anderes angebaut haben,
keine Ideen mehr hatten, irgendwas anderes
angebaut haben,
dann hatten sie wieder was anderes.
Es ist so random,
wir und für den Arsch, Alter.
Naja.
Macht aber nix.
Story kannst du dich ja übelst schnell durchklicken.
Ich meine, du musst die Story immer spielen.
Du musst die Kampagne einmal spielen, am Anfang von einer Liga.
Kommst ja nicht drum herum.
Oder by the way, kommt man mittlerweile
drum herum? Also das letzte Mal, wo ich
gespielt habe, bist du nicht drum herum gekommen.
Dann musstest du die Kampagne immer noch spielen.
Am Anfang von einer Liga mit einem Charakter musstest du,
nein, du musst es theoretisch
mit allen neuen Charaktern machen, aber
du musst es zumindest einmal
musstest du die
Kampagne spielen, pro Liga.
Zumindest,
worauf ich eigentlich
raus will,
neben dieser blöden Kampagne,
Path of Exile hat einfach nur alles
aufeinander drauf gepackt.
Und es ist so krass,
wenn du heutzutage versuchst, in Path of Exile
einzusteigen,
das ist für Newcomer eigentlich
nicht möglich,
in einer Liga einzusteigen
und dort was auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Das ist einfach zu viel.
Du musst das Spiel erst mal zwei Jahre gespielt haben,
dass du aufgeholt hast, was du verpasst
hast und dann den Schritt halten mit den neuen.
Es ist so
unglaublich vieles Zeug.
Das beste Beispiel, was ich euch
zeigen kann, wo man das ganze
sieht, so,
Path of Exile selbst
reicht nämlich nicht mehr aus, um das Spiel zu
spielen.
Du brauchst beispielsweise extra
Skillplaner dafür,
die dann so aussehen.
Damit du überhaupt checken kannst,
ob es irgendein Bild ist, das was
taugt und nicht.
Also das ist ja schon der normale
Skilltree, aber hier kannst du quasi im
Vorfeld alles schon durchplanen.
Du musst Path of Exile mit so ein paar Tools spielen,
sonst klappt das nicht.
Also du brauchst mindestens,
ich bin mir bei den Namen nicht mehr ganz sicher,
wie gesagt, schon zwei Ligen her, wo ich gespielt habe.
Du brauchst mindestens Path of Building,
du brauchst mindestens dieses
Ingame-Price-Zeug-
Overlay-Gedöns,
was es da gibt.
Du brauchst den Currency-Tracker,
dass du weißt, ob es das lohnt,
was du machst.
Und generell für die ganzen Ingame-Mechaniken,
du musst das studieren, ohne Scheiß.
Ich würde behaupten,
Path of Exile ist, was
Knowledge angeht,
so Ingame,
Ingame-Wissen, was man einfach haben
muss, ist es das komplexeste
Spiel, was es gibt.
Item-Filter, sorry,
das ist das Allerwichtigste, habe ich ganz
vergessen, ja. Benutzt man heute noch diese
Plate, wie heißen diese Plate?
Plate-Filter oder so?
Diesem Typ.
Custom-Sounds für die Filter brauchst
du auch, sonst übersiehst du die Hälfte.
Also es ist so
...
Also das
ist wirklich ultrakomplex.
Es gibt, glaube ich, kein komplexeres
Game, so rein von, was du,
wo ich jetzt nicht meine,
wo du super krasse Reflexe brauchst,
wo der Gegner hinläuft, ich meine, reines
Wissen
der nackten Zahlen und Fakten
und
Path of Exile erklärt ja auch nicht wirklich viel.
Da gibt es, glaube ich, kein Game, was
so komplex ist, wie Path of Exile.
Ich habe das schon einige hundert Stunden
gespielt, aber ich mache immer mal wieder ein bisschen
längere Pause und skippe auch mal eine Liga und sowas.
Und ich würde behaupten, ich blicke nicht
mal im Ansatz durch,
dass ich wüsste, was ich mache,
wenn ich keinen Guide hätte.
Ja, also Path of Exile ist echt so
ein Spezialding, man.
Fällt euch irgendein Game ein
mit ähnlicher
Komplexität, so Knowledge-mäßig?
Also mir nicht.
Tetris.
Tetris ist genau
umgedreht, auch wenn kapper.
Tetris ist ein ultrakrasses Skill-Game.
Weniger ein reines
so Knowledge
PoE-Style-Game.
Ich weiß nicht, ob League und Dota
auf ähnlichem Niveau ist in der Richtung wie
PoE.
Bei PoE
ist es halt so, du musst halt
sau, sau, saumäßig viel
wissen, dass du überhaupt was machen
kannst, gescheit. Und in
LoL ist es auch noch ein gehöriger
Portion, du musst das zur richtigen
Zeit, am richtigen Ort, mit richtigem Timing
und richtig ausführen alles.
Bei PoE
ist das, ist die
kleine Execution eigentlich lachhaft.
Ja, jeder Dreijährige kann PoE
spielen, wenn du ihm sagst,
welche Tasten er drücken muss.
Aber die Sache drumherum ist
halt das Komplizierte.
Mein PoE, ich war in
PoE, äh, nicht PoE, äh, in BDO
war ich, war ich drei Jahre, vier, fünf
Jahre oder so, fünf Jahre oder so nicht mehr eingeloggt.
Das letzte, was ich in BDO gemacht habe,
ich hab meinen Account umgezogen
von
dem US-Anbieter
zu, zum
koreanischen Anbieter.
Ja gut, das stimmt schon, das ist auch viel.
Gerade, aber
noch eine Sache,
was man an LoL und Dota
sieht, dass es kein reines Knowledge Game
ist, wo du nur was wissen
musst, die Interaktion
zwischen den ganzen
Champions und zwischen den möglichen
Compositions, die ein Team haben kann.
Du musst zwar wissen,
was die ganzen Champions machen,
ja, und was die können und
wie die sich spielen, so ungefähr,
zumindest,
aber die Interaktion dazwischen,
die kannst du
nicht
in allen Kombinationen üben.
Da ist auch viel Intuition dabei,
weil, überlegt euch mal,
wie hoch ist die Kombination aus
140 Champions
versus 140, okay, es sind nicht wirklich 140
Champions, weil es gäbe jetzt was weg von,
ja, wie viel, wie hoch sind die
Kombinationsmöglichkeiten? Die Kombinationsmöglichkeiten
sind so hoch, du kannst nicht
jede Team Composition,
mit jeder quasi Lane Position,
wo jeder Champion irgendwie dann sein
kann, geübt
haben versus die anderen möglichen
Compositions. Das geht nicht.
Ja, du musst wissen, was die machen,
wie die sich spielen, was du dagegen machen
kannst, aber
du kannst das nicht so durchplanen und PoE ist
halt durchplanen von Anfang bis Ende.
PoE ist, könnte man fast sagen,
eigentlich 95%
Planung, 5% Runterspielen.
Weil der Gameplay Aspekt
von PoE ist wirklich nicht sonderlich komplex.
Wenn ihr euch mal
High End PoE Builds anguckt,
da werdet ihr außer Effekte
und
ab und zu mal einen Loot Filter Sound
eigentlich gar nichts mitbekommen.
Zoom
Bäm, Zoom Bäm, Zoom Bäm, Zoom Bäm,
Boom, drop, Zoom Bäm,
Zoom Bäm, okay, Map fertig, nächste
Map, Zoom Bäm, so läuft
PoE Endgame.
So, ja lasst uns mal
angucken, was auf Shithub
diese Woche trendet.
Shithub, ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung,
wenn es Shithub ist, dann ist es auch Shandalf
anstatt Scandalf.
Sherlock trendet, juckt mich nicht.
AI wird auch trenden.
Gibt es jetzt einen
Currency Exchange in PoE?
Wie einen NPC,
wo man direkt traden kann?
Normalerweise muss man
das ja über Trade Channel machen.
Was ist der Vorteil von einem NPC, der
das macht versus Trade Channel?
Ah, der Vorteil ist
die Self Found Geschichte.
Was ist am Trenden?
By the way, ich muss mal gucken,
ob es neue
User
neue Tickets gibt.
Ah ja.
Alles User Probleme,
alles Anwender Fehler.
Okay, also lasst uns mal kurz gucken, was trendet.
Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht.
Juckt mich nicht.
AI, bestimmt
AI, würde ich mal vermuten.
One Click Face Swap.
Was könnte nur schief gehen
mit so einer Software, Leute?
Wir wissen alle,
was das erste ist, was die Leute mit so einer
Software machen.
Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich auch nicht.
Wollte ich mal ausprobieren, schon seit
einer ganzen Weile.
Spotify Downloader, okay, das ist nice.
Das ist bestimmt auch
möglich, ohne dass man dort einen Account hat.
Die laden Songs runter.
Geht das ohne Account?
Die laden Songs runter, quasi ohne Werbeunterbrechung,
ohne alles, so dass man...
Das ist natürlich cool.
Also, Paid Account, meine ich.
Open Observe, das haben wir schon mal ausprobiert.
Das war noch nicht ready,
als wir es ausprobiert haben.
Aber es scheint so, als sind die
da ganz schön heftig am
developen dran.
Wir haben das vor einem halben Jahr oder so mal ausprobiert, gell?
Also, da hat sich
wohl einiges, da tut sich ja wirklich
laufend was.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was mein Kritikpunkt daran war.
Ich glaube, ein paar Sachen gingen einfach nicht,
die ich machen will. Wo ich gesagt habe, okay, dann
bringt es mir das jetzt auch nicht so.
Sonne tanken.
Ah, das
kenne ich, ja, was du gerade gepostet hast.
Das habe ich schon gesehen. Warum?
Weißt du, was ich nicht verstehe, bei diesen
ganzen Deepfake-Sachen?
Warum deepfaken die immer
Elon Musk? Können die nicht
irgendwann... Immer wird Elon Musk deepfaked.
Hat der so ein
besonders sich gut für Deepfake eignendes
Face, oder...
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber Elon Musk wird schon deutlich mehr deepfaked.
Ist das so?
Es gibt ja auch
genug Videos mit Elon Musk, wo man sich denkt,
Alter, was erzählt der denn da? Und die sind echt...
Was ist denn das hier? Sonne tanken.
evcc.io
Das ist bestimmt was für
IO-Broker, hm? Nee.
Bringt mir das was?
GoEcho? Okay, mein Ladegerät
ist supported.
Moment, was genau?
Das bringt doch aber nur was, wenn man
eine...
Wenn man Solarzellen oder so auf dem Dach hat, ne?
Ach ja, okay, das kann dir ausrechnen,
was du quasi selbst verbrauchst, davon...
Gut, weil für mich bringt das nix.
Das ist nicht, dass irgendwie
mein Ladegerät dadurch neue
tolle Features kriegen würde, oder so.
Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich,
nach Twitter hält er sich jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen zurück mit
ich kaufe XY. Das lief bei Twitter ja auch
nicht so gut. Wobei wisst
ihr eigentlich, dass Twitter sich selbst
gekauft hat, wenn man es mal genau nimmt?
Vermisst du irgendwas beim
GoE-Charger?
Also mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass
das Ding halt
ein bisschen billig
zusammengeschustert aussieht.
Funktioniert das gut?
Ja doch, eine Sache könnte ein bisschen besser sein.
Die hätten
eine ordentliche WLAN-Antenne einbauen können.
Der
GoE-Charger, also dieses Ding hier.
Also ich habe dieses Teil hier als
Ladegerät.
Ich habe noch den alten.
Also meiner sieht
eher noch
so aus. Keine Ahnung, was die
Pro-Variante und so macht.
Ja.
Wobei, meiner sieht auch...
Ich glaube, ich habe noch einen älteren.
Meiner ist blau, oder?
Ja.
Ja, so sieht meiner aus, genau.
Also nicht mit diesem...
Meiner ist direkt fest verbaut
und hat nicht so ein Ding. Genau, meiner ist auch noch
blau. Das meine ich, das Ding sieht ein bisschen
aus, als hätten sie das in
irgendeiner Garage daheim zusammengeschustert aus.
Aber okay.
Also was sie hätten machen können,
was ich sehr nice gefunden
hätte, ist
eine bessere WLAN-Antenne drinnen.
Tatsächlich, ja.
Weil da ist ein
ESP32 drinnen.
Passt mal auf. Oh, guck mal, da hat es ein bisschen
abgefackelt bei ihm.
Kommt euch das Ding hier bekannt
vor? Kommt euch das da oben
bekannt vor, Chatge?
Das Ding? Kannst du bestimmt
selber upgraden. Wahrscheinlich.
Ich will das aber nicht aufmachen und da drinnen
rumbasteln.
Kommt euch dieses Board hier irgendwie bekannt
vor? Das gab es bei mir
im Stream auch schon öfters zu sehen.
Das ist ein
ESP2866 NodeMCU.
Sieht zumindest
ganz stark danach aus.
Das hatten wir auch schon öfters.
Das ist ein
bisschen älterer,
WiFi-fähiger,
Microcontroller. Haben wir hier im Stream auch schon
benutzt. Und so ein Ding
steckt da halt einfach drauf. Und
das hat eine Onboard-Antenne. Man sieht
es jetzt gar nicht. Also hier ist der eigentliche Microcontroller
drunter. Das hier sind eigentlich nur
die I.O. Pins.
Man könnte theoretisch das
Motor drauf flashen. Das würde funktionieren.
Ja. Aber
bringt dir ja nichts, weil das Motor den Kram
nicht richtig ansteuern kann.
Und guck mal, die haben sogar noch ein USB
dran, dass du per USB flashen kannst.
Und die WLAN-Antenne,
die man jetzt hier nicht sieht,
die ist unten auf dem Board
drauf. Guck, das ist
das Board.
Hier ist die WLAN-Antenne.
Ah, hier hinten, wo das Kabel ist. Man sieht das
leider nicht.
Ja doch, hier, guck, hier.
Hier ist die WLAN-Antenne. Das ist
die Antenne. Dieses
aufgeätzte
Kupferding. Oder abgekratzte
Kupferding. Das ist die WLAN-Antenne
von dem Ding.
Das hier.
Hier. Das da.
Und dementsprechend ist jetzt
die Reichweite und der Empfang
nicht das geilste.
Okay? Wenn man das sieht,
kann man sich das, glaube ich, denken.
Deswegen wäre es gut gewesen, die hätten ein Board
genommen mit externen Antennenmöglichkeiten.
Hätten einfach eine externe Antenne reingebaut.
Also der Empfang ist
nicht so geil WLAN-technisch
von dem Ding. Aber Rest
kann ich eigentlich nichts sagen. Also
das Problem, was er hier hatte, dass das irgendwie
abgefackelt ist oder so.
Weiß nicht.
Es funzt eigentlich erstaunlich gut.
Und was das richtig Gute
daran ist, was übrigens auch der Grund ist, warum ich
das Ding gekauft habe,
weil die
lokale HTTP-API haben,
Modbus-API
und OCPP kenne ich
und eine MQTT-Schnittstelle.
Das heißt, du kannst dieses
Ding wunderbar
offline steuern.
Warum braucht man bei einer Ladestation WLAN
ja zum Beispiel, dass du mitbekommst
in einer Heimautomatisierung, wenn der Ladevorgang
fertig ist.
Das ist das erste Beste, was mir jetzt einfällt.
Wenn du Statistiken haben willst,
wie oft lädst du, wie viel lädst
du, ist natürlich auch sinnvoll.
Möchtest du remote das Laden ein- und
ausschalten können, ist das auch sinnvoll.
Zum Beispiel
ist es so, dass man bei vielen Autos
das Laden zwar remote starten
kann, aber das
Laden nicht remote beenden
kann. So, hallo Fiat.
Und damit kannst du das Laden auch remote
beenden, indem du es einfach ausschaltest an der Ladestation.
Hat schon seinen Sinn, wenn man da
remote drauf zugreifen
kann. Muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt bei WLAN sein, bietet sich aber an.
Irgendwas, was wäre die Alternative zu
WLAN? Zigbee oder sowas.
Das war der Grund, warum ich mir das gekauft habe.
Weil du die Möglichkeit hast, es lokal
zu steuern über HTTP oder MQTT.
Und das
funktioniert echt ganz gut.
Ja, ich hatte da keine Probleme mit.
Das einzige Problem ist, wie gesagt, dass der WLAN-Empfang
nicht der allerbeste ist, wegen dieser Furzantenne da drinnen.
Ich, jaja, das Problem
ist, es ist noch nicht mal das Problem, dass
ich die Garantie verliere.
Das Ding ist eh, glaube ich, mittlerweile schon älter
als zwei Jahre. Ich will das nicht
aufschrauben.
Das Ding hängt
direkt unten
am Verteilerkasten im Keller dran.
Wenn ich das einfach aufschraube und da drinnen
rumlöte, ist keine so gute Idee.
Ich müsste
erstmal gucken, an welcher Sicherung das hängt, die Sicherung
rausmachen.
Und dann habe ich aber keinen Bock drauf,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich werde da nicht dran rumbasteln.
Es funzt ja aktuell.
Der WLAN-Empfang, sage ich nur, wenn es eine Sache gibt,
die ich nicht gut finde, dann ist der WLAN-Empfang.
Der WLAN-Empfang könnte besser sein.
Bei mir geht es ja. Ich meine, ich habe einen Accesspoint
im Keller stehen und
einen Accesspoint hier oben
im ersten Stock.
Das deckt ja das ganze Haus ab.
Ja. Deswegen, ich habe
da kein Problem mit. Aber insgesamt
könnte das ein bisschen stärkere
WLAN-Empfang sein.
Ein bisschen bessere Antenne verkraften.
So.
Ich rufe das hier mal zu.
Das ist nur eine Sache. Nochmal gucken.
Gerade die GitHub-Trends. Was trendet
denn heute ganz aktuell?
Keine Ahnung.
Docker OS X.
Juckt nicht. AI.
Coolify. Weekly.
Weekly trendet. Okay.
China-Chinesen-Weekly.
Das gibt es noch.
Ist von Microsoft? Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja. Der Rest ist nicht so interessant.
Okay. Ok.
Meta.
Ja. In der heutigen Zeit wäre es
durchaus sinnvoll, sowas anzubieten mit
WLAN und Meta. Beziehungsweise, das stimmt ja
gar nicht. Du kannst ja Meta über WLAN
machen. Meta ist ja eigentlich nur
die...
die Logik, das Protokoll
da oben drüber.
Nicht die Übertragung. Also, du kannst
Meta über WLAN machen. Du kannst auch Meta
über Zigbee im Endeffekt machen oder über
Thread. Also, wenn heute
einer sowas anbietet,
dann würde ich sagen, es wäre sehr sinnvoll,
tatsächlich
neben WLAN
auch noch Zigbee oder Thread
und Thread zu unterstützen.
Einfach,
dass du möglichst breit kompatibel bist.
Auf der anderen Seite, ey, wenn du
WLAN-Unterstützung hast, dann hast du doch
eigentlich zu 90 Prozent...
Die Ladebox hängt ja meistens
nicht so weit weg vom Schuss, dass kein WLAN-Empfang
ist. Wobei, weiß ich nicht.
Manche Leute mit einem großen Hof und einer
Garage, vielleicht ist da kein WLAN-Empfang
mehr. Kann schon sein.
Wäre möglich.
So, lasst uns mal gucken, was...
Nein, nein, nein, wir gucken jetzt nicht hier. Was können wir uns
heute mal angucken? FreeBSD
in 100 Sekunden. Okay.
Ich werde die Faszination von Roblox
nie verstehen. Was ist das?
Wollen wir uns nachher an...
Bösartig. Das üble Geschäft
mit Wasser. Eieiei.
Platin-Sarangische für den Sub.
Excellent.
Massive Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Und ich muss mal nachgucken. Ich hab bestimmt wieder die Hälfte
vergessen. Nee, hab ich nicht.
Alles gut.
Ja, ich sag jetzt ja auch nochmal, ich bin mir nicht
sicher,
wie lange ich heute am Start bin. Ich hab's gestern ein bisschen
übertrieben. Ich war gestern drei Stunden Fahrradfahren.
Und auch sehr holprig.
Äh, am Boden. Und ich merk's heute
übelst im Rücken.
Ich hab deswegen auch ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen.
Haben wir ja oft, wenn man ein bisschen Verspannung im Rücken hat.
Und...
Weiß ich nicht, wie sinnvoll das ist, jetzt drei Stunden
oder so am Rechner zu setzen. Erstmal so nach dem Aufstehen.
Moin Max, ich möchte mir mal laufen
an der Suche gut Laufschuhe zu machen. Kannst du mir...
Ja, kann ich. Zumindest die, die
ich benutzt habe, kann ich dir empfehlen.
Bei mir hatte das zwei Gründe, warum
ich mir die gekauft hab. Erstens,
weil ich ein bisschen schwerer bin und was schönes
Gedämpftes haben wollte. Was aber eh zum Einstieg
sehr sinnvoll ist. Und auch weiterhin
immer sinnvoll ist. Schöne, äh,
Kaschenschuhe.
Was nicht so auf die Beine geht.
Äh, und ich hab mir Laufschuhe rausgesucht, die es in
breit, in extra breit gibt, weil ich ziemlich
breite Füße hab. Ja.
Also, ähm, was ich habe, ist
den hier. Also, ich benutze
nicht ASCII.
Nombus.
Immerhin.
Ja. Also.
Ich hab den hier.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich den... Ich glaube, ich hab...
24 ist meiner, ne?
Ich hab noch den hier. Den, den, den...
Den von letztem Jahr.
Äh, der sieht aber anders aus. Aber...
Oh, da gibt's schon 26
schon? Ah, Moment. Okay.
Sorry. Ich hab den 25.
Den 26er gibt es schon. So rum
ist es.
Ja. Also, ich
hab... Genau, genau, genau. Ich hab den
in...
Meiner ist... Nee, nee, nee. Meiner ist
so blau und orange.
Letztendlich ist die Farbe aber vollkommen egal.
Der hier ist nice.
Den gibt es
auch, falls du breitere... Falls du breitere
Füße hast, gibt es
den auch in...
extra... in extra
breit. Okay, gibt's das grad nicht.
Den gibt's dann aber nur in einer Farbe.
Oder nee, in zwei Farben.
Ah. Der sieht
stylisch aus, hm? Ja.
Also,
den, den, die Schuhe hab ich.
Es gibt schon ein Nachfolgermodell 26.
Da scheiden sich aber die Geister dran,
ob der
wirklich besser ist. Manche sagen,
sie wollen weiter mit dem 25er
laufen. Manche sagen, ja, der
26er ist ein bisschen stabiler als
der 25er. Also, man muss sich da dran
gewöhnen. Wenn du damit anfängst
zu gehen, kommst du dir vor, als wenn du
auf Marshmallows läufst.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr wobbly,
wenn du da drauf läufst.
Wenn du darauf anfängst zu joggen,
also, ich mein, wenn du gehst, ja? Wenn du gehst,
dann ist das sehr wobbly, aber sobald
du anfängst zu laufen damit, oder zu joggen,
dann passt das.
Und das Neueste daran ist,
wenn du das jetzt nicht verwendest, um neue Bestzeiten
aufzustellen, dann würde ich den nicht unbedingt
anziehen, ist der halt
sehr bequem. Und dadurch,
dass der so ne, der hat auch so ne coole
Gummilasche,
ja, die verkantet auch nicht.
Der sitzt gut,
ist mega bequem, und halt
auch für die Beine recht
angenehm, weil die Dinger sehr
stark dämpfen.
Ja, man sieht das hier auch, wenn man sich das
mal in einem Video anguckt.
Wir gucken uns das Video jetzt nicht an, ich will's bloß mal
zeigen, ob der, ob der vielleicht mal drauf
drückt, oder so.
Ja, ein bisschen sieht man's ja schon.
Ja, ja.
Der wiegt halt auch nix.
Okay, aus, aus irgendwelchen Gründen kriegen wir das
hier, ja. Da müsste man ein Video sehen,
wo die draufdrücken.
Da siehst du, wie, wie stark das überhaupt
nachgibt, ja? Also, das ist schon,
das sinkt, das sinkt schon zur Hälfte
ein. Drücken alle nicht drauf,
haben da keinen Bock, oder? Wird nicht
draufgedrückt. Die zeigen ja einfach nur,
so. Egal. Der ist,
kann ich dir empfehlen, den hab ich auch.
Kann jemand mit Pas, mit Ob,
Objekt Pascal? Nö.
Aber du bist der Delphi-Meister.
Dann müsstest du doch das
eigentlich auch hinkriegen. Ist doch nicht so viel
Unterschied. Stripes, dankeschön für den
Sub. Pog.
Okay.
Was haben wir denn auf YouTube, was wir uns angucken können?
Komm, wir gucken uns das FreeBSD-Video
an.
Fireship, Fireship ist immer nice.
FreeBSD.
By the way,
die Playstation
läuft auf FreeBSD.
Ich glaube sogar seit der PS2
schon. Also unter der Haube
basiert die Playstation auf
FreeBSD. Hast du dir schon
Black Ops 6 angesehen? Angesehen schon,
gespielt nicht.
Guck. Er hat's sogar hier drinnen.
Ja.
Ne.
Okay,
mit diesen
gibt es die
die
ähm
ihr habt vielleicht schon mal was in der
Richtung verwendet, ähm, nämlich
wer OpenSense verwendet
oder das
FreeNAS verwendet hat.
Schunas?
FreeNAS?
Das ist das Gleiche, ne? Die haben sich umbenannt.
Das war auch BSD.
BF-Sense, OpenSense.
Ja, und unter der Haube
ist das Ganze auch unter MacOS und
iOS drunter. Stimmt, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Please allow me to interject for a moment.
Es ist nicht Linux,
es ist GNU plus Linux.
Leute,
vielleicht ist ja nächstes Jahr
nicht das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Sondern das Jahr des BSD-Desktops.
Ist es nicht so, dass die
mittlerweile sogar...
Haben die nicht in BSD mittlerweile auch
den Teile des
ZFS-Linux-Codes?
Now, when a machine boots up,
it runs an init-system to configure the machine
and run daemons in the background.
That's typically SystemD,
but FreeBSD takes a more traditional approach
with RC-Scripts.
When it comes to packages,
you can install them as binaries
just like a .deb or .rpm file.
Or you can use the ports collection,
which is a framework of make files and patches,
custom tailored for installing applications
from source.
This has been FreeBSD in 100 seconds.
Das war aber sehr kurz und klackig.
And you're now one of the rare humans
who can say, I use FreeBSD by the way.
But an operating system is useless
until you learn how to use it to solve problems
in the real world.
Developing your problem-solving skills for free today.
Jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen Sellout hintendran.
Ja, viele Teile des Internets
laufen mit FreeBSD.
Das fliegt bei vielen Leuten
komplett unterm Radar.
Und auch, dass so Dinger
wie die Playstation auf BSD laufen.
Ich glaube, es hat da, wie gesagt, der PS2
auch nicht so bekannt.
Ne, was willst du in 100 Sekunden
da großartig reinpacken noch?
Verwaiste Autos auf Parkplätzen.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Ich fahre ganz gerne so Richtung Spessart
ab und zu eine Runde wandern.
Und auf dem einen Parkplatz
steht seit über einem Jahr schon
ein Auto.
Irgendein alter Opel
oder ever, keine Ahnung.
Der hat schon Heu drauf
auf dem Fenster
und der hat schon Moos
an der Seite angesetzt.
Also, ich glaube, der
ist da auch,
ist auch verwaist.
Aber ich bilde mir ein,
der hat sogar noch ein Nummernschild
dran gehabt.
Es vergeht keine Woche,
wo FireShip nicht drei AI-Videos
hochlädt, ja.
Ich kann es dem aber nicht
mal übel nehmen.
Die Videos laufen immer richtig gut.
Und als Content-Creator
musst du halt leider gucken,
dass du schon so ein bisschen
zumindest die Welle mitschwimmst,
was so Trends angeht.
Was nicht heißt, dass du nicht
zwischendurch auch andere Sachen
machen kannst, die dir vielleicht
mehr am Herz liegen.
Ein bisschen mitmachen
ist von Vorteil oftmals, ja.
Ich nutze jetzt Linux
für einen Minecraft-Server.
Hab's nur nicht hinbekommen,
den Bildschirm ganz auszuschalten
und dass ich ihn zuklappen kann
und dann...
Moment, was?
Du hast ein altes Notebook
zweckentfremdet quasi, ja.
Wenn du hart drauf bist,
unloadest du einfach den Grafiktreiber,
falls das funzt an der Stelle.
Und du kannst,
du kannst bestimmt den Grafiktreiber
blacklisten beim Boot.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert,
aber theoretisch müsste das funktionieren.
Ja.
Ja, Notebooks
und Linux ist so ein Ding.
Ich wüsste jetzt auch keinen...
Doch, mit X-Runder
könnte man, kannst du wahrscheinlich.
Du kannst bestimmt mit X-Runder
kannst du deinen Bildschirm ausschalten
irgendwie, gell?
Geht das nicht irgendwie?
Kann man doch nicht sagen,
irgendwie bla bla bla und dann irgendwie off?
Monitor off oder so?
Irgendwie Screen bla Dings off?
Das funzt, glaube ich,
aber das probiere ich jetzt hier nicht aus.
X-Run hat nicht geklappt.
Ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Dann lass es einfach an.
Die paar Watt, keine Ahnung,
drei Watt zusätzlich da oder so.
Ja, da kannst du die Helligkeit verstellen,
aber ob du ganz ausschalten kannst,
weiß ich nicht, ne?
Vielleicht, vielleicht hast du Glück
und du kannst der Display Input umschalten.
Auf...
Auf den VGA Output oder so
und dann so aus.
Wo ist dein Homelapse Setup Video?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob ich ein Homelapse Setup Video habe.
Hast du ein spezielles Video im Kopf,
was du mal gesehen hast
und jetzt wieder suchst?
Oder meinst du allgemein,
ob es eins gibt?
Ich glaube, so ein komplettes Setup Video
habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich habe meinen Serverraum
ein paar Mal gezeigt,
wo man die Switch und die...
3D-Drucker und das ganze Zeug sieht.
Aber so ein ich laufe mal durch mein Haus
und zeige die ganzen Sachen überall,
habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Da könnte ich euch vor allem mal
meine High-IQ
Heizungs-Wasserdruck-Konstruktion zeigen.
Ich habe mir ja bei Amazon so was gekauft,
hier vor einer Weile.
Das haben wir auch im Stream gemacht,
so eine Wifi-Valve.
Nix mit Hafen.
Nix mit Half-Life zu tun.
So ein Ding habe ich mir mal gekauft
vor einer ganzen Weile.
Im Prinzip ist das ein Motor
mit einem kleinen Microcontroller,
wo du quasi Ventile drehen kannst.
Und die habe ich aufgemacht,
habe an das Relay für den Motor
einen D1 Mini dran gelötet,
mit das Motor drauf.
Und jetzt kann ich über meinen Home Assistant
den Wasserdruck für meine Heizung steuern.
Also ich habe da unten auch so ein Ding.
Und wenn die Heizung ein bisschen
wenig Wasserdruck hat,
dann drücke ich auf den Knopf
bei mir im Home Assistant.
Dann macht das Ding das Ventil auf.
Die Heizung kriegt ein bisschen mehr Wasser,
und dann mache ich das Ventil wieder zu.
Das ist eine echt coole Konstruktion.
Das Dashboard habe ich mal gezeigt in einem Video.
Aber da gibt es auch nicht so großartig was zu sehen.
Das Dashboard habe ich mal hier gezeigt.
So halbwegs.
Home Assistant Dashboard.
Home Assistant Dashboard,
das habe ich mal gezeigt.
Das sieht im Großen und Ganzen
immer noch so aus,
wobei das halt ein bisschen
ältere Home Assistant Version ist.
Da gibt es nicht so viel.
Hier unten, hier ist das,
hier zeige ich das, guck mal.
Hier sieht man nämlich die Kamera
mit der Druckanzeige von der Heizung.
Und wenn die Druckanzeige zu weit unten ist,
dann drücke ich auf meinen Knopf.
Man sieht es doch.
Sieht man das hier auch irgendwo?
Hier.
Heizungsdruck.
Eigentlich total bescheuert benannt das Ding.
Wenn ich da drauf drücke,
dann geht dieses Wifi,
dieses Wifi-Ventil-Steuerungsding hier an,
dreht das Ventil auf an der Heizung
und dann gucke ich hier drauf auf die Kamera
und wenn es gut ist, mache ich wieder aus.
Ich mache alles offline.
Ich mache nichts in der Cloud.
Sehe ich nicht ein.
Eines ist für mich eines der wichtigsten Voraussetzungen,
wenn ich mir Smart Home Sachen kaufe,
dass ich die gescheit offline verwenden kann.
Leider, muss man sagen,
fucken dich da die Hersteller oftmals so ein bisschen im Nachhinein ab.
So nach dem Motto,
ja, ja, Offline-Steuerung, kein Problem.
Nach dem nächsten Update geht es nicht mehr.
Oder wir schalten es jetzt ab oder solche Dinger.
Das ist manchmal ein bisschen kacke.
Deswegen am liebsten benutze ich Hardware,
die ich custom flashen kann.
Zum Beispiel mit das Motor drauf
oder ich habe auch teilweise Sachen mit meiner eigenen Firmware drauf.
Aber Sachen, wo ich quasi das bestimmen kann,
was drauf läuft.
Deswegen habe ich,
ich habe ein paar Überwachungskameras.
Ich habe am Hoftor war es,
ich habe für den Hof,
für den Keller unten,
das, was ihr gesagt habt.
Ich glaube, ich habe fünf Stück oder so.
Und das sind China-Kameras,
aber China-Kameras mit lokalem RTSP.
Das sind Reolink-Kameras.
Das sind billige China-Dinger hier, die ich habe.
Ich kann ja allerdings nicht mehr sagen,
welche Kameras ich genau habe.
Ich habe eine,
ich habe eine im Hof hängen,
die sieht der hier relativ ähnlich.
Man muss bei denen aber genau gucken,
weil die haben Kameraversionen mit lokaler Möglichkeit
und welche, die nur über die Cloud gehen.
Und Sachen, die nur über die Cloud gehen,
sind halt komplett für den Arsch.
Kannst vergessen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel so eines,
von diesen Kameras hängt im Hof bei mir
und da gehe ich per RTSP dran
und rufe den Stream ab.
Fertig.
Dann habe ich noch zwei alte,
noch zwei alte Wisecams.
Nee, nicht mal die, die eckige.
Die gibt es gar nicht mehr hier.
Noch die, noch die alten,
zwei alte Wisecams
mit custom geflashter Firmware.
Ganz praktisch,
weil die haben so einen magnetischen Fuß
und hängen dran.
Ja, die hier im Keller,
die ich euch gerade im Video gezeigt habe,
die, so eine Wisecam,
weil das ist praktisch,
die klebt quasi so an der,
das ist so eine Metalltonne
gegenüber von der Heizung.
Da klebt die dran mit dem magnetischen Fuß.
Ansonsten habe ich Reolink-Kameras.
Die sind nicht sonderlich geil.
Ja, die sind auch sehr schwachbrüstig,
was CPU und sowas angeht
und die haben auch manchmal ein paar Fehler im Stream.
Aber das Gute ist,
die haben einen lokalen RTSP-Stream.
Sobald du einen lokalen RTSP-Stream hast,
ist gut,
wenn das funktioniert,
ohne Cloud-Verbindung.
Ja, es gibt ja auch Kameras,
die schalten sowas ab,
wenn sie keinen Ping in die Cloud kriegen
und sowas.
Was nimmst du als Backup?
BambuLab kenne ich gar nicht.
Was ist BambuLab?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Das ist jetzt irgendeine 3D-Drucker-Geschichte.
Was ich benutze,
ich habe so ziemlich die einfachste
Backup-Variante überhaupt.
Ich habe eine externe Festplatte
an meinem Server
und da wird nachts drauf geair-synced.
Verdammt.
Was für ein Sensor ist das
für die Luftqualität?
Das kann ich dir zeigen,
weil...
Leute,
passt mal auf.
Jetzt.
Premiere.
Weil mir vom Fahrradfahren
ein bisschen der Rücken weh tut.
Premiere, Leute.
Es kann sein,
dass ich gleich weg bin,
weil ich irgendein Kabel abgerissen habe.
Premiere,
ich verwende zum ersten Mal im Stream
meinen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Ich hoffe,
es fällt nichts runter.
Oh.
Knapp.
Close.
Die Xbox hängt an der Tischkante.
Okay.
So.
Ich habe es nur gerade gehört,
dass es so ein bisschen gemacht hat.
Okay.
Xbox verschoben.
Moment, Moment.
Tisch.
Also, da seht ihr mal,
ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Aber ihr könnt euch überlegen,
wie oft ich den verwende,
wenn ich jetzt nicht mal weiß,
ob der fehlerfrei hoch und runter fährt
oder irgendwie was abgerissen wird.
Okay.
Ich muss mal...
Ich muss mal ein Ohr
raus machen.
Oh.
Was ist das?
Moment.
Ah.
Geht.
Hört ihr es eigentlich?
Hört ihr eigentlich im Hintergrund,
dass das jetzt so macht?
So irgendwie?
Ja.
Okay.
Nice.
Excellent.
Hört man nicht.
Zu gutes Noise Cancellation.
Excellent.
Sehr schön.
Gefällt mir.
Hey,
mein Schreibtisch ist mal wieder oben.
Sachen gibt es.
Ich habe mir diesen Schreibtisch extra geholt.
Ein Jahr oder so,
nachdem ich hier eingezogen bin.
Höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch.
Richtig gut für den Rücken.
Ich habe den dreimal verwendet
und nie wieder hochgefahren.
Eigentlich sollte ich das machen,
weil ich sitze so viel vorm Computer.
Ich sitze acht Stunden Homeoffice-technisch
vorm Computer.
Ich sitze danach vorm Computer.
Also,
es hat sich ja im Vergleich zu früher
nichts geändert.
Außer,
dass ich jetzt regelmäßig
eine Runde rennen gehe
und ab und zu mal
1,
2,
3 Stunden Fahrrad fahren gehe.
Ich sollte,
wenn ich...
Also,
Wenn ich...
für mich selbst
wäre es wahrscheinlich sehr sinnvoll,
wenn ich einfach
50% des Tages
an diesem Stehstreibtisch
wirklich stehen würde.
Weil stehen einfach
um ein Vielfaches
gesünder und angenehmer
auch für den Rücken ist,
als auf
halb acht Shep sitzen.
Wo sind wir gerade stehen geblieben?
Was wollte ich euch denn jetzt zeigen?
Ich wollte euch...
Luftqualität.
Da habe ich einen von Ikea.
Mal gucken.
Das habe ich gestreamt.
Bille ich mir ein.
Ja.
Den hier habe ich.
Hier.
Ikea.
Windrichtning.
Heißt das
Windrichtung
oder was?
Windrichtning.
Excellent.
Oh,
was ist da los?
Wort lädt nicht.
Doch,
Wort lädt.
Da ist er.
Da lä...
Aber,
freu dich mal nicht zu früh.
Ich kann dir den nicht empfehlen.
Genau.
Also,
wir haben nämlich noch ein bisschen
Luftqualitätssensor.
Und zwar,
wir haben ein ESP32 eingebaut,
damit ich die Werte abgreifen kann vom Luftqualitätssensor.
Und,
wir haben noch einen BMP280,
glaube ich,
angeschlossen.
Für Luftfeuchtigkeit und Temperatur.
Ja,
hier unten ist der Luftqualitätssensor.
Das ist hier mit diesem Lüfter,
der dann quasi ein bisschen Luft dem Ding zuführt.
Ich kann dir das Ding aber nicht empfehlen.
Ich habe den Sensor nicht...
Ja,
also,
ich kann dir das Ding nicht empfehlen,
weil das zu schnell verstaubt.
Das verstaubt so schnell,
dass du das eigentlich einmal im Monat sauber machen musst.
Und reinpusten reicht nicht.
Wahrscheinlich muss man den Staubsauger dran halten.
Und,
noch wahrscheinlicher müsste man sogar aufmachen und absaugen.
Also,
der hat mir zu hohe Maintenance Intervalle,
dieser Sensor.
Deswegen benutze ich den mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Ich sehe den ja,
der steht hier mir gegenüber,
steht ja hier auf dem Schrank.
Aber das war es auch,
der ist aus.
Ja,
hier wurde gelöt-champed.
Ey,
hier war noch nicht alles.
Ja,
hier habe ich alles dran,
genau.
Ja,
hier sieht man es,
hier ist alles dran jetzt.
Guckt hier,
ist der Microcontroller dran,
der Luftfeuchtigkeit-Temperatursensor.
Und am Ende haben wir uns das auch hinter das Motor angeguckt,
dass das alles funktioniert.
Wie machst du das Chat-Fenster so schön?
Du meinst,
dass es so transparent ist,
oder meinst du die Katz dabei?
Meinst du das hier unten?
Das ist ein Browser-Overlay.
Unter der Haube ist das ein Browser.
Browser mit einer transparenten Hintergrundfarbe.
Einfach Browser.
Kannst du auch machen.
Browser,
Browser-Source in OBS hier.
Ich zeige es jetzt,
ich zeige es jetzt nicht genau,
das hat irgendeinen Custom,
ein Custom-Link.
Das ist von,
ich glaube,
Streamlabs oder so.
Aber es ist im Prinzip eine Browser-Source
mit einem transparenten Hintergrund.
Ich muss gleich eine Runde Nacken- und Rückenmuskelübungen machen.
Chat,
wollen wir das zusammen machen?
Wollen wir zusammen eine Runde?
Nee,
ihr liegt noch alle im Bett.
Das machen wir,
bevor ich Mittagessen gehe.
Bevor ich Mittagessen gehe,
machen wir zusammen 15 Minuten.
Ja,
Rücken- und Nackenmuskelübungen.
Weil ihr seid auch alles Kellerkinder wie ich
und hockt den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner.
Ups.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Was haben wir hier?
Ist diese KI-Halskette illegal?
Omi.
Moment,
die testen nicht die Oma.
Omi.
Das ist doch wieder irgendwie,
das ist irgendein AI-KI-Schwachsinn,
den keiner braucht,
weil er,
predikte ich jetzt einfach mal,
überhaupt nichts mit KI zu tun hat.
Man schreibt einfach mittlerweile überall KI drauf.
Ob es was mit KI zu tun hat oder nicht,
ist egal.
Da muss ich sagen,
ich bin ja da selbst schuldig.
Und zwar beim alten Arbeitgeber,
da ging es mal drum,
jetzt habe ich euch,
da habe ich schon mal erzählt,
da ging es ja drum,
da haben wir mal,
da gab es mal so einen,
so einen Ideen-Wettbewerb,
was man cooles Neues machen kann.
Und da habe ich gesagt,
ey,
Leute,
unsere Knowledge-Base und Doku ist so scheiße,
also ich habe das natürlich ein bisschen schöner verpackt,
weil die ist so kacke,
da findet niemand was drin.
Wollen wir nicht die Sachen in irgendeinen Chatbot füttern,
und dass man den Chatbot dann fragen kann?
Und nachdem sich das irgendwie keiner vorstellen kann,
wisst ihr, was ich gemacht habe?
Ich habe eine Webseite gebaut,
die hardcoded Chatantworten drin hatte.
Da konntest du dann zum Beispiel fragen,
was gibt es heute Mittag in der Kantine?
Und wenn er das Wort Kantine gematcht hat,
dann hat das Ding halt einfach ausgegeben,
es gibt heute bla bla bla.
Das ging auch nur für den Demo-Tag,
für keinen anderen Tag ging das.
Da habe ich das Ding aufgemacht,
habe das gezeigt,
da kann man dir den Chatbot fragen,
das war die hardcodedste,
unintelligenteste Sache ever.
Hatte mit einem ordentlichen Chatbot
und Indizierung von Null nichts,
aber auch gar nichts zu tun.
Aber ich habe das Ding gezeigt,
das fanden sie alle toll.
Also, heutzutage wird jeder Scheiß als KI verkauft.
Habe ich mir gedacht,
können wir doch auch mal machen.
Dabei habe ich einfach nur die Antworten hardcoded.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Komm, wir gucken uns das jetzt an.
Ich will eigentlich nur wissen,
ob ich Recht habe mit dem,
was ich gerade gesagt habe,
dass es mit KI wahrscheinlich wieder nichts zu tun hat
und jeder KI draufschreibt,
obwohl eine KI nicht drin ist.
Guck mal hier, eine Halskette,
die eine Wanze ist.
Ja, wirklich, ich habe hier die sogenannte...
Guck mal hier, eine Halskette,
die eine Wanze ist.
Ja, wirklich, ich habe hier...
Das Ding sieht auch hässlich wie die Nacht aus, oder?
Das sieht aus wie ein schlecht 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein schlecht 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse.
Die sogenannte Omi-Halskette um den Hals.
Vorher hieß die Friend und die kostet 60 Euro.
Da ist ein Mikrofon drin und die hört permanent zu.
Also wirklich permanent.
Die schickt die ganze Zeit aus,
das ist ja wunderbar gepaart mit dieser Windows-Software,
die dein Desktop permanent aufzeichnet.
Da hast du alles.
Da hast du permanente Desktop-Aufzeichnungen bei Microsoft
und permanente Sound-Aufzeichnungen bei Omi.
Exit, das ist das Brauch.
Audio-Dateien in die Cloud und lässt die dort transkribieren.
Ganz toll.
Und wahrscheinlich auch ganz toll für die Leute,
die dir über den Weg laufen und mit dir reden,
dass dann ihre Sachen auch in der Cloud sind.
Ach, wahrscheinlich ist das,
deswegen illegal,
weil du Leute aufzeichnest,
die dir kein Einverständnis gegeben haben dazu.
Es gibt auch eine Zusammenfassung jedes einzelnen Gesprächs,
was ich so führe.
Also jedes Gespräch, was ich erlebe,
egal ob privat oder beruflich oder sonst was.
Und noch krasser.
An sich, mal von ganzen Datenschutz-Bedenken und alles mal weg.
Oder auch, was macht der Anbieter mit den Daten?
Alles weg.
Ist das eine praktische Sache?
Wie oft habe ich mir schon überlegt,
so nach dem Motto, Moment,
was hat die jetzt gesagt?
Soll ich um 10 Uhr oder um 11 Uhr da sein?
Und so solche Gedanken.
Das hat ja jeder öfters.
Ah, Mist, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja, oder wie war das vor zwei Wochen,
wo ich beim Bäcker war?
Was habe ich da nochmal bestellt und so?
Da ist das sicherlich praktisch.
Ist halt die Frage, ob die...
Es ist praktisch, die Bedenken überwiegen,
die ich habe mit sowas.
Und aktuell ist das nicht der Fall.
Ich habe mehr Bedenken, als dass ich es praktisch finde.
Ja, mitschreiben.
Da musst du ja mitschreiben.
Da musst du dir erstmal drüber Gedanken machen,
okay, ist das jetzt so relevant,
dass ich mitschreiben muss?
Und ja, ich schreibe jetzt mit.
Und ich schreibe doch beim Bäcker nicht mit.
Aber vielleicht denke ich mir trotzdem in drei Wochen,
was habe ich das letzte Mal bestellt?
Also, es ist schon praktisch.
Gerade, wenn das automatisch transcribed wird.
Das funktioniert ja.
Meine Streams werden auch immer schief,
alle automatisch transcribed.
Deswegen kann man,
also falls ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt,
hier nochmal zeigen,
was der Max da wieder für high IQ Sachen gebaut hat.
Also nicht ich, sondern der Serious Max.
Also du kannst hier zum Beispiel,
Wort, wenn wir jetzt hier mal suchen nach,
Keck W zum Beispiel,
dann sieht man, dass ich hier um 2 Stunden,
41, 53 Sekunden habe ich Keck W gesagt.
Moment, lass mal überprüfen, ob das stimmt.
Keck W.
Siehst du?
Also das transcriben von meinen Streams,
also prinzipiell ist diese Technik ausgereift.
Okay, weiter.
Omi verspricht, dass es aus dem ganzen täglichen Laberbrei
einzelne Termine raushört
und die dann automatisch in meinem Kalender speichert.
In diesem Video finde ich heraus,
ob man womöglich eine Straftat begeht,
wenn man das Ding benutzt
und auch, ob das Gerät die versprochenen Funktionen
wirklich liefert.
Okay, ich nehme das zurück.
Es sieht nicht aus wie ein Schlechtradio.
Es sieht nicht aus wie ein schlecht 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse.
Es sieht nämlich nicht aus wie ein 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse
oder jetzt nicht mehr in der Nahaufnahme.
Es sieht aus wie ein insgesamt sehr
gewöhnlich gemachtes Gehäuse.
Kleiner Spoiler schon mal.
Ich habe zwischendurch wirklich daran gezweifelt,
ob das wirklich wahr ist,
was ich da auf meinem Smartphone Display gesehen habe.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei
Also wenn ihr euch auch so einen Spitzel-Anhänger kaufen wollt,
dann sind euch eure Privatsphäre
und eure persönlichen Daten
Und was kommt jetzt? NordVPN?
Ach nee, nicht ziemlich egal.
Aber wenn euch eure eigenen Daten am Herzen liegen,
dann könntet ihr euch mal Incogni anschauen,
die sponsern nämlich dieses Video.
Ja, und Incogni, das ist ein Dienst,
der automatisch eure persönlichen Daten
aus den Fängen von Datenhändlern befreit.
Chatgear, ich habe gerade in meinem Tee,
ich habe ganz stinknormalen Kamillentee,
da ist irgendwelche...
irgendwelche Bröckchen drinnen gerade.
Ich frage mich, wo die herkommen.
Vermutlich ist es nicht so gesund,
wenn ich das weiter trinke.
Ich lasse das mal lieber.
Ja, es gibt leider hunderte von diesen Datenhändlern,
die eure Daten entweder legal
oder sogar illegal aus irgendeinem Server einbrüchen.
Okay, wir skippen mal kurz die Werbung.
Also, das hier ist der Omi-Anhänger.
Und falls ihr jetzt denkt, hä?
Da war doch neulich schon mal so ein Ding Thema bei 3003.
Das hieß aber...
Reste von der Blüte?
Nee.
Das ist ein Teebeutel, da ist nichts mehr drin.
... oder so.
Ja, das ist korrekt.
Da ging es aber nur um die Ankündigung eines...
Aus dem Wasserhahn? Möglich, ja.
... solchen Mithöre-Anhängers.
Und wir haben ja jetzt einen da.
Es gibt einen kommerziellen Nicht-Open-Source-Anhänger,
der heißt Friend und ist bislang nicht erhältlich.
Es gibt aber auch einen Open-Source-Anhänger,
der schon länger in Entwicklung ist.
Und ja, der hieß bislang auch Friend,
der heißt Omi, unbenannt.
Und das wird vermutlich mit dem Nicht-Open-Source-
Friend-Anhängermachern zu tun haben.
Die haben ihr Produkt nämlich laut United States Patent
und Trademark Office als Marke angemeldet.
Nick Shevchenko, der...
Man kann das Wort Friend
als Marke anmelden?
Ja, der ist Open-Source-Anhänger.
Man kann auch Apple als Marke anmelden, warum nicht?
Ja, der hat auch einen Rap-Diss-Track
gegen den anderen Friend-Macher hochgeladen.
Aber, okay.
Ich habe hier jetzt also die Open-Source-Variante
namens Omi um den Hals hängen.
Und da ist tatsächlich nicht nur die Software Open-Source,
sondern auch die Hardware.
Man kann sich das Ding mit Standard-Bauteilen
und einem 3D-Drucker selbst bauen.
Also, ich muss jetzt selber nochmal auf die...
Okay, doch, schlecht 3D-gedrucktes Gehäuse.
Seed Studio Shao NRF52840
Synth Board ist das Herzstück.
Da muss man...
Ich kenne das Board jetzt nicht,
aber das ist irgendein Funk-Ding.
Macht durchaus Sinn, ja.
...einen Dings,
noch einen Akku einbauen
und das Gehäuse 3D-drucken
und einen Schalter einbauen und so.
Da hatte ich keine Lust zu,
deswegen habe ich das Ding komplett bestellt.
Das hat dann inklusive Versand 60,90 Euro gekostet.
Ja, okay, und dann hat der Zoll halt nochmal
17,38 Euro obendrauf berechnet.
Keine Ahnung, was da schiefgelaufen ist.
Ist auch egal.
Jedenfalls sieht das Ding tatsächlich auch
sehr selbstgebastelt aus.
Er hat zumindest Glück gehabt, dass er anscheinend
nicht hin musste zum Abholen.
Recycle-Story, ich weiß,
ich habe schon 350 Milliarden mal erzählt,
aber es triggert mich jedes Mal, wenn ich an Zoll denke.
Ich habe mir einen Ambilight bestellt
für meinen Fernseher.
So ein Ambilight zum Nachrüsten.
So ein Ding habe ich mir bestellt.
So ein Set.
Gibt es mittlerweile nicht mehr,
die Seite ist auch weg.
Da wird quasi der Bildinput
wird quasi umgewandelt zu einem
du klebst dir so LED-Streifen
im Endeffekt.
Im Endeffekt klebst du dir LED-Streifen
hinten am Fernseher
und der macht dann den Bildinhalt
zu PAM.
Sieht dann so aus.
Ist eigentlich sehr cool.
Habe ich seit Jahren schon
und funzt auch ziemlich gut.
Immer noch.
Zumindest so ein Ding habe ich mir bestellt.
Gab es damals nur in den USA zu bestellen.
Also bestellt, passt.
Die kümmern sich um Zoll und alles natürlich wie immer.
Bei allem, was ich aus den USA bestelle.
Die Chinesen kriegen das deutlich besser hin.
Lohnt sich das?
Ja, ich finde schon.
Ich finde das ist sehr praktisch.
Ich habe ein sehr günstiges Setup dafür.
Bei mir, weil ich habe
einfach eine leere
weiße Wand dahinter.
Die ganze Wand ist einfach nur weiß
und leer hinter meinem Fernseher.
Man sieht sie übrigens im Hintergrund glaube ich ein bisschen.
Dass es was macht.
Aber das ist einfach zu hell.
Naja.
Zumindest, wie so immer
bei Sachen aus den USA
die Chinesen kriegen das besser hin.
Die schreiben da einfach irgendeinen Grab drauf.
Der Zoll glaubt das dann.
Die Amis kriegen es nicht hin.
Es landete beim Zoll.
Und dann musste ich zum Zoll hin.
Und der Typ wollte von mir wissen,
was es ist da drinnen.
Also wie gesagt.
So was habe ich bestellt.
Ja, der ist ein bisschen outdated.
Auch mit Standards und sowas.
Also so eine Box habe ich bestellt.
Da habe ich ihm das gezeigt.
Das ist ein Ambilight Nachrüstkit
für ein Fernseher.
Und dann hat er das Wort Fernseher gehört.
Und hat in seiner Liste
weil beim Zoll ist es so
du musst auf unterschiedliche Güter
unterschiedliche Sachen bezahlen.
Und dann sagt er zu mir.
Ah ok Fernseh.
Und guckt dann in seiner Liste für Fernsehgeräte nach.
Nein, nein.
Da ist kein Fernseh drinnen.
Das ist ein Nachrüstkit.
Mit LEDs und sowas.
Was man an den Fernseh dran macht.
Und dann wusste er nicht
welche Gerätekategorie das ist.
Meine Güte ey.
Ich weiß nicht was er dann
am Ende eingetragen hat.
Riesenakt alter.
Bis ich dieses Package hatte.
Ich meine das Ding ist
so groß wie eine Hand ungefähr.
Wie kann man ernsthaft denken
dass das ein Fernseher ist.
Gut da ist ein Screen vorne drauf.
Ok ganz ehrlich.
Wenn ich mir nur das Bild angucke.
Wenn ich mir nur den Namen
und das Bild angucke.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Kann ich schon nachvollziehen
dass man sagt ok wird ein Screen sein.
Aber Beleuchtung.
Wahrscheinlich war es dann am Ende irgendwas mit Beleuchtung.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Was er genau.
Zumindest habe ich das dann bekommen.
Ganz ehrlich DHL verzollen
ist das aller beschissenste ever gewesen.
In Leipzig.
Wo ist der DHL Zoll?
Leipzig.
Das sind die aller geilsten gewesen.
Habe ich auch in den USA bestellt.
Bei irgendwelches Microcontroller Zeug.
DF Droid oder so.
Irgendwo habe ich Microcontroller Zeug bestellt.
In den USA.
Ich habe angekreuzt
dass die sich um den Zoll und alles kümmern sollen.
Und auf einmal
liegt das ganze dann beim Zoll Leipzig.
Liegt ewig rum und hin und her und sonst was.
Eigentlich sollten die sich da drum kümmern.
Auf einmal kriege ich eine Mail.
Ich soll Sachen ausfüllen.
Leute das macht doch der Hersteller alles.
Und irgendwie haben sie es halt alle nicht hingekriegt.
Und ich kann mich nur noch an eine Sache erinnern.
Ich habe dann beim Zoll Leipzig.
angerufen und wollte von ihr wissen.
Wie ist das denn jetzt?
Ich habe das hochgeladen.
Im Status tut sich immer noch nichts.
Was ist denn jetzt?
Was passiert denn jetzt?
Und da sagt sie zu mir am Telefon.
Das kann ich Ihnen auch jetzt nur nicht sagen.
Oder so in der Richtung.
Mit sächsischem Dialekt.
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Da steht doch da ich soll hier anrufen.
Wenn ich es nicht weiß.
Ja das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Jetzt.
Das war auch sehr hilfreich.
Der Zoll in Leipzig.
Zumindest.
Ich bin zu dem Schluss gekommen.
Kannst du vergessen.
Also habe ich dem Hersteller in den USA geschrieben.
Hab gesagt.
Leute ich weiß es liegt nicht an euch.
Aber ich habe das Ding Express bestellt.
Und ich habe das mit.
Zoll.
Management bestellt.
Und es hängt jetzt schon seit fast einer Woche im Zoll.
Wenn es jetzt noch eine Woche braucht.
Dann ist es zu spät da. Dann brauche ich es nicht mehr.
Ich werde dann die Annahme verweigern.
Und das zurückgehen lassen.
Es liegt nicht an euch. Ihr könnt nichts dafür.
Aber was soll ich denn machen.
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Die Amis haben sich darum gekümmert.
Die Amis haben am nächsten Tag da angerufen.
Und einen Tag später was freigegeben.
Hätte ich gleich machen sollen.
Anstatt mit der vom Zoll zu telefonieren.
Gut. Gucken wir mal weiter.
Definitiv mit der Bastelschere ausgeschnittene Danke Zettel.
Aber auf jeden Fall hat das Teil auf Anhieb funktioniert.
Ich habe die benötigte App auf meinem iPhone installiert.
Auf Koppeln gedrückt und fertig.
Das war wirklich sehr unfrickelig.
Und jetzt ist das Teil wirklich permanent mit meinem Telefon verbunden.
Und transkribiert alles.
Moment.
Im Prinzip hat das doch gar nichts mit AI zu tun.
Das Ding ist einfach nur ein Mikrofon mit Batterie.
Mikrofon, Batterie, Bluetooth.
Die Aufnahmen werden ans Smartphone übertragen.
Das Smartphone lädt das hoch in die Cloud.
Läuft dann im Endeffekt irgendeine Transcribe-Geschichte drüber.
Wie teuer.
Was hat es gekostet?
60 Euro hat er dafür bezahlt.
Also im Prinzip kannst du das selbst machen.
Das ist ein nettes Gadget für permanent Mikrofon mit Akku.
Ich kann euch jetzt live zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
ct 3003 ist der tollste YouTube-Kanal der Welt.
Schubidum. Schwupp die Zität.
Lieblingswort, was, ja, also ich heiße Keno und wohne in Hannover.
Schwuppdizität, das kann das?
Sage komische Sachen ins Mikrofon, um die Transkription zu testen.
Und eigentlich müsste das da jetzt stehen, ich kann leider nicht sehen, was da gerade passiert.
Aber theoretisch müsste das gerade mit transkribieren.
Ja, und dieses Transkribieren, das macht es halt wirklich den ganzen Tag.
Anders als zum Beispiel bei aktuellen Google- oder Samsung-Smartphones,
die ja lokal auf dem Gerät transkribieren können,
macht OMI quasi eine Standleitung zu dem Transkriptions-Cloud-Service Deepgram auf
und streamt da permanent alles hin, was das Mikrofon so hört.
Also der OMI-Anhänger ist mit Bluetooth mit meinem Telefon gekoppelt,
das Handy streamt das Audio zu Deepgram.
Im Prinzip ist da dran null AI.
Das ist ein Mikrofon an einer Batterie, was per Bluetooth ans iPhone die Sachen überträgt
und das iPhone lädt das hoch.
Und Deepgram...
Das Ding hat wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einen Speicher.
Ich hoffe, die haben in der App einen Buffer, wenn die Internetverbindung nicht funktioniert.
...schickt Text zurück.
Und pro Stunde gingen da bei meinem Test übrigens mehr als 80 Megabyte Daten rüber.
Also gerade unterwegs mit Mobilfunk-Internet kann das teuer werden.
Und die permanente Übertragung geht natürlich auch auf den Akku des...
Siehste, so weit sind wir in Deutschland schon, dass 80 MB die Stunde teuer werden können.
Für den Arsch, ne?
Telefon.
Und der Akku vom OMI-Anhänger selbst, der hält erstaunlich lange,
nämlich bis zu sechs Tage.
So, aber jetzt wird's krass.
Man kriegt nicht nur jedes im Alltag gesprochene Wort als Text geliefert,
sondern die Software erkennt die jeweiligen Gespräche auf und fasst sie dann zusammen.
Das passiert natürlich auch in der Cloud über einen AI-Dienstleister.
Kurzer Einschub, ganz wichtig.
Ich hab natürlich bei...
Warum hatte der da gerade einen SNES-Controller in der Hand?
Habt ihr das auch gesehen?
Steuert er damit vielleicht seine Aufnahme?
Kann das sein, dass er das als Fernbedienung benutzt?
Mein Test ist, immer alle Personen vorher...
...um Erlaubnis gebeten, dass ich die Gespräche mit dem Ding hier transkribieren lasse, ne?
Also, ganz wichtig.
Ja, und auf jeden Fall funktioniert diese Erkennung und Zusammenfassung gruselig gut.
Also, da hab ich manchmal wirklich gedacht, ist das hier Zauberei oder was?
Also, ohne dass ich irgendwas mache.
Also, ich sag jetzt nicht, hier fängt jetzt ein neues Gespräch an, hier hört das alte auf,
sondern das klappt alles komplett automatisch.
Ach so, ja, und die Gespräche können auf Deutsch sein,
aber die Zusammenfassung zeigt die App bislang nur englischsprachig an.
Hier seht ihr zum Beispiel die Zusammenfassung eines 3003 Teams.
Und das stimmt tatsächlich alles.
Und das Krasse ist, dass da sogar Action-Items rausdestilliert worden sind.
Also, konkrete Aktionen, die einzelne Teammitglieder machen wollen.
Und noch krasser, wenn das System irgendwo im Gespräch einen konkreten Termin raushört...
Das Coole bei der Sache ist halt, dass das im Nachhinein eben durchsuchbar ist.
...auf Wunsch automatisch in den Kalender eintragen lassen.
Und auch das, muss ich leider sagen, hat in meinen Tests gut funktioniert.
Also, das System hat seinen eigenen Namen falsch geschrieben, also,
Omi mit H und auch Heizkette statt Halskette gehört.
Aber naja, steckt noch in den Kinderschuhen.
Das Erstaunliche ist sowieso, dass die Transkription oft unvollständig ist und auch so komisch fragmentarisch,
aber dass die Zusammenfassungen daraus sind trotzdem gut, weil, ja, die KI schließt die Lücken.
So, und jetzt denkt ihr wahrscheinlich, zwischen so einem Arbeitsmeeting und so einem privaten Gespräch,
da liegt ja sicherlich auch einige Zeit Pause dazwischen.
Ja, ich habe deshalb mal als Experiment zwei Ausschnitte aus YouTube-Videos direkt ohne Pause hinbekommen.
Und zwar mit exakt den gleichen Sprechern und, um das noch etwas schwieriger zu machen, sogar mit Regiolect.
Also, einmal Elden Ring die ganze Geschichte auf Hessisch und einmal Halo die ganze Geschichte auf Hessisch.
Beide von Game Two.
Und ja, das Omi-System hat die Themen nicht nur korrekt erkannt, sondern auch wirklich gut zusammengefasst.
Achtung, wenn ihr keine Spoiler zu den Spielen sehen wollt, mal kurz vorspulen.
Was ist denn Halo auf Hessisch? The Master Chief oder was?
Was ist denn, was...
Ja, das habe ich wirklich einfach direkt hintereinander abgespielt.
Und da hat er sofort alles erkannt, obwohl es die gleichen Sprecher waren.
Oder hier bin ich einfach Schuhe kaufen gewesen.
Und ja, das wurde auch erkannt.
Ich habe wirklich Schuhgröße 47.
Also, die Omi-Software packt dann auch an jedes Gespräch so einen Tag dran.
Also, sowas wie Arbeit, persönlich, sozial oder Gesundheit.
Ja, und ihr hört da...
Das kenne ich nicht, ne?
Ich finde das Ganze rein aus technischer Sicht sehr beeindruckend.
The Master Chief fließt auf den Halo-Ring.
Oder wie? Darf man sich das dann überlegen?
Das... Ich meine...
So in der Richtung muss das sein.
Der Master Chief steigt ins Flugzeug.
Ja.
Und ja, ich kann mir sogar vorstellen, warum man das praktisch finden kann.
Alleine dieses automatische Termine eintragen, das finde ich schon auch ziemlich praktisch.
Aber für mich steht auch ganz klar fest, dass ich das Teil nach diesem Test nicht mehr benutzen werde.
Weil das einfach allen anderen Menschen um mich herum total unfair und rücksichtslos gegenüber ist.
Das stimmt wohl.
Natürlich wollen die meisten Menschen nicht, dass ihre privaten Gespräche mit mir archiviert werden.
Im Arbeitsumfeld ist das Ganze meiner Erfahrung nach etwas weniger unbeliebt, aber auch da gibt es natürlich viele Leute, die das...
Es ist sicherlich per Policy bei vielen Läden gar nicht erlaubt, dort irgendwie was mitzuschneiden, ohne dass es klar ersichtlich ist.
Also, eventuell bist du da sogar nur ganz knapp auch von der Abmahnung entfernt, wenn man sowas macht.
Verständlicherweise nicht.
Interessant ist übrigens auch...
Wird keiner merken.
Wirst keine Abmahnung kriegen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht erlaubt.
Auch wer eigentlich die API Kosten für das ganze Zeug bezahlt.
Also, wenn ich mir hier die Open Source Version anschaue, dann muss ich da eigene API Tokens reinwerfen.
Aber hier in meiner Version, da ist das alles freigeschaltet.
Das heißt, ich kann 24 7 Audio in der Cloud transkribieren lassen und zusammenfassen lassen.
Das kostet ja Geld.
Da lohnt sich doch eigentlich schon so ein Ding zu kaufen, den API Key abzugreifen, was garantiert irgendwie möglich ist und das dann selbst zu verwenden.
Da hast du die 60 Euro schnell wieder drinne.
Also, der Macher von dem Projekt, Nick Shevchenko, ja, der sitzt in San Francisco.
Der ist 24 Jahre alt, hat schon zwei Startups verkauft und sagt, er sei ein Peter Thiel Fellow, also dem durchaus imstrittenen Silicon Valley Milliardär.
Das kann sein, dass das Geld von Investoren oder so kommt.
Wir haben Shevchenko mal gefragt und bislang keine Antwort bekommen.
Wenn da vor Veröffentlichung des Videos was eintrudelt, dann würde ich das hier jetzt reinschneiden.
Ja, kurz vor Veröffentlichung des Videos hat sich Nick Shevchenko gefragt.
Ja, kurz vor Veröffentlichung des Videos hat sich Nick Shevchenko tatsächlich ganz freundlich bei uns gemeldet.
Wegen Zeitzonenproblemen, sag ich mal, haben wir allerdings kein Interview mehr vor Veröffentlichung hinbekommen.
Ich werde aber sehr wahrscheinlich trotzdem mit ihm sprechen und das, was ich rausbekomme, schreibe ich dann in einen angepinnten Post in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr noch was wissen wollt von ihm, könnt ihr mir das auch schreiben.
Ich versuche, ihn das dann zu fragen.
Aber ich habe am Anfang ja angekündigt, es gibt ja im deutschen Strafgesetzbuch den Paragrafen 201.
Ja.
Das heißt Verletzung der Vertraulichkeit des Wortes.
Und da steht drin, mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe wird bestraft, wer unbefugt erstens das nicht öffentlich gesprochene Wort...
Leute, es geht nicht um das Hochladezeitpunkt des Videos, es geht um den Schnittzeitpunkt des Videos, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Die haben die Sachen ja im Vorfeld schon produziert, ja.
Das sind ja nicht so planlose Leute wie ich, denen sonntagmorgens einfällt, ach, man könnte mal was aufnehmen.
Dann setze ich mich hin, schwätze eine Stunde, schneide ein bisschen was zusammen und lade was hoch.
Das ist schon etwas besser geplant bei denen, würde ich mal vermuten, ja.
Eines anderen auf einen Tonträger aufnimmt oder zweitens eine so hergestellte Aufnahme gebraucht oder einem Dritten zugänglich macht.
Ich versuche dazu noch eine rechtliche Einschätzung zu bekommen, die schneide ich euch hier gleich noch rein.
Also wenn wir uns beide jetzt unterhalten und ich erzähle dir von meinem letzten Arztbesuch...
Und ich weiß nicht, dass du gerade deinen Schmerz hast.
Nicht, dass du gerade einen schönen Halsschmuck an deinem Nacken trägst, sondern dass ein Gerät ist, was unser Gespräch aufzeichnet.
Dann kann es sein, dass du dich strafbar machst.
Denn nach § 201 StGB wird geschützt die Vertraulichkeit des Wortes und insofern, dass nicht öffentliche Gespräche nicht aufgezeichnet werden dürfen.
Etwas anderes ist es im Datenschutzrecht.
Dürft... Chat? Was ist, wenn ich euch jetzt was Persönliches erzähle und ihr speichert das Ganze?
Kann ich euch dann verklagen?
Für jede Verarbeitung von personenbezogenen Daten, also das Gerät speichert ja immer das Gespräch,
ist es so, dass diese Daten, die da aufgezeichnet werden, eine Datenverarbeitung sind.
Und eine Datenverarbeitung darf ich immer nur dann vornehmen, wenn eine Rechtsgrundlage vorliegt.
Und da die Eingriffe in das Persönlichkeitsrecht...
Ja, ich habe es vermutet.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Neues Geschäftsmodell.
Einfach privates Zeug im Stream erzählen und danach alle Leute verklagen, die zugehört haben.
...denkbar im Datenschutzrecht eine Einwilligung...
Ja.
Streamer hassen diesen Trick.
...Einwilligung und mit der Einwilligung ergeben sich dann weitere Probleme.
Beispielsweise ist es so, dass die Einwilligung immer widerruflich gegeben werden muss.
Das bedeutet, wenn ich dir eine Einwilligung gebe, musst du gewährleisten, dass, wenn ich die Einwilligung widerrufe, dass dieser Widerruf auch gegenüber dem Anbieter...
Bässe, hier.
Simons Cat Hintergrund.
Guck ich auch öfters mal.
...dann durchgesetzt wird.
Und das ist oftmals schwer umzusetzen.
Schwierig ist auch die Tatsache, dass Einwilligungen dokumentiert werden müssen, denn sonst könnte ich ja sagen, ich habe dir gar keine Einwilligung gegeben.
Dann ist es schwierig, dann bist du in einem Beweisproblem und müsstest mir dann sagen, ja, nein, du hast mir ja aber aufgeschrieben, du hast mir deine Einwilligung gegeben, hier steht das.
Also das ist in der Praxis eigentlich kaum umsetzbar.
Ja.
Und dann muss die Einwilligung auch informiert erfolgen.
Das bedeutet, du musst mir erzählen, wenn du dieses Gerät nutzt, was alles da passiert in der Datenverarbeitung.
Und da wird es immer ganz schwierig bei KI, wenn selbst Entwickler beispielsweise nicht genau wissen, was die KI macht.
Wie soll, willst du mir denn dann erzählen, was KI mit meinen Daten macht?
Dass das alles natürlich sehr, sagen wir mal, sehr viel Grauzone dabei ist, ist auch klar.
Weil was meint ihr, wie viel ungefragte Mitschnitte, Aufnahmen und private Informationen dritter Leute beispielsweise über WhatsApp verbreitet werden?
Ja, das ist streng genommen auch nicht legal.
Insofern haben wir hier auch ein Problem.
Und dann habe ich noch gar nicht angefangen von Geschäftsgeheimnissen.
Also beim beruflichen Umfeld ist ein Einsatz von solchen Geräten definitiv abzusehen.
Mein Fazit.
Eine KI-gestützte, komplette Selbstbespitzelung, die scheint ja wirklich für viele Leute sehr interessant zu sein.
Also nehmen wir mal Microsofts geplante Recall-Funktion.
Oder halt, dass solche Ganztagesaufnahmegeräte direkt von zwei unterschiedlichen Startups parallel entwickelt werden.
Aber bei mir und bei euch, also wenn ich mir eure Kommentare so anschaue, stößt solches...
Bei den großen Language Models, da kann dir keiner genau sagen, wie die zu ihrem Ergebnis kommen.
Das wissen die Entwickler selbst nicht.
...Zeug in die Hand.
...Zeug eher wenig auf Gegenliebe.
Also wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommt, so ein Teil fürs Privatleben benutzen zu wollen.
Also das Problem mit der Unfairness gegenüber meinen Gesprächspartnerinnen und Partnern habe ich ja schon erwähnt.
Aber stellt euch mal vor, irgendwer bekommt Zugriff auf die Transkripte aller eurer privaten Gespräche.
Also da dreht sich mir wirklich der Ma...
Ist sehr unangenehm, ja, sehr unangenehm.
Und ich denke, dass das nicht nur mir so geht.
Ich finde aber auf jeden Fall wichtig, darüber zu berichten, weil ich möchte gerne wissen,
dass da draußen solche haben.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ich finde auch, dass da so eine Art und Software existiert.
Für berufliche Meetings sehe ich sowas allerdings differenzierter.
Allein, weil da ja eh oft manuell mitgeschrieben wird, also oft auch in die Cloud mitgeschrieben wird.
Also das jetzt zu automatisieren, dagegen sprechen zwar auch ein paar Sachen.
Und zwar natürlich Falschtranskriptionen, die können, wenn man sich da ohne Überprüfung darauf verlässt,
natürlich für riesige Probleme sorgen.
Natürlich kann bei menschlichem Mitschreiben auch mal gesagt werden, so das und das mal jetzt bitte nicht notieren.
Das ist jetzt nur für diesen Raum.
Da kann man vermutlich irgendwie mit umgehen.
Das ist ja auch längst eine Funktion, die zum Beispiel Microsoft in Teams anbietet.
Aber eine komplette 24-7-Aufzeichnung des Alltags.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es viele Leute gibt, die da keine Bauchschmerzen haben.
Oder?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Was meint ihr dazu, Leute?
Also ich hätte dabei sehr große Bauchschmerzen.
Aber was meint ihr, wie es so bei den ganz, bei der ganz Jungen quasi nicht mal mehr so ist,
nicht mal mehr Zoomer-Generation aussieht,
sondern bei denen, die jetzt wirklich so quasi komplett native damit aufgewachsen sind,
für die es das Normalste der Welt ist.
Was meint ihr, wie das da ist?
Wie ist da eure Einschätzung?
Denkt ihr, das wäre was?
Oder jeder Politiker muss das tragen.
Das wäre doch tatsächlich mal was Sinniges.
Könnte man auch wenigstens nachvollziehen, was da so geht.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass das in ein paar Jahren durchaus ein akzeptiertes Gadget ist.
Zwar nicht in der Form, wie es da jetzt ist.
Ja, da gibt es dann noch irgendwas anderes.
Dann hat mittlerweile Apple oder sowas eingebaut in die Smartphones.
Aber es wird immer akzeptierter werden, sowas.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, es ist doch auch so, weil wenn du hier sagst,
und ein T-Shirt tragen mit dem Aufschrift, dieses Gespräch mit dem Aufschrift.
War es nicht so,
dass wenn du schwarz fährst in der U-Bahn und ein T-Shirt anhast mit,
wo draufsteht, ich fahre schwarz oder so,
dass es dann kein Schwarzfahren mehr ist,
weil du es nicht versteckt hast.
Und ein T-Shirt hast mit, ich habe kein Ticket.
Ich habe da irgendwo mal was zugelesen.
Das ist Schwarzfahren,
dass es auch diese extra Strafgebühr für Schwarzfahren nur gibt,
wenn du das versuchst zu vertuschen und zu verstecken.
Wenn du quasi sagst, ey, Kollege, ich habe kein Ticket,
dann darfst du keine Strafe beweisen.
Dann darfst du keine Strafe bekommen extra noch zusätzlich obendrauf.
Übrigens gerade zum Thema U-Bahn.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen,
da habe ich auch wieder an der Menschheit gezweifelt,
was da los ist.
Ist random bei mir aufgeploppt.
Das ist random bei mir aufgeploppt auf Twitter.
What the fuck, Alter.
So schlimm ist es noch nicht mal in Frankfurt.
What the fuck.
Ich weiß nicht, warum Twitter mir das letzte Mal empfohlen hat.
Es sieht auch noch so übelst bescheuert aus.
Guckt euch die Leute drumherum an.
Die hier, die denken sich auch,
what the fuck, nicht schon wieder.
Nicht schon wieder.
Ja, die Menschheit ist der durchschnittliche C++-Programmierer.
Du meinst, das ist undefined behavior, was wir da sehen, ja?
What the fuck.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne den Hintergrund nicht.
Das wurde mir nur letztens auf Twitter vorgeschlagen,
weil ich gerade gesagt habe, U-Bahn, ist mir das wieder eingefallen.
Ich dachte, ich muss das mal kurz zeigen.
I can't wait.
So, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Wir müssen mal kurz eine Runde Katzenvideo gucken.
Ginger, remember this?
Ja, gut, sowas.
Da flippen die aus drauf.
Do you want some candy?
Ja.
Natürlich, das ist dafür.
Also generell, raschelnde Tüten sind schon mal extrem spannend.
Und je nachdem, was da drin ist,
wenn das Tee ist oder Katzenminze oder sowas,
also auf Teebeutel ging Chico ab.
Chico ist die hier.
Die hier, die ungefähr hier so auf der Höhe ist gerade.
Chico ging ultra auf Teebeutel ab.
Och ja.
Das findet die ganz toll.
Ja, das ist irgendwie Katzenminze oder Baldrian oder irgendwie sowas.
Da flippen die voll drauf aus.
Das ist quasi, das ist ungefähr so,
wie wenn du dir am Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof was kaufst bei irgendeinem Dealer.
Für die Katz.
Ich hatte auch so ein Baldrian-Kissen.
Ich habe das schon mal gesehen.
Mit so Baldrian-Geruch, der da rauskam.
Da sind die Katzen auch bei mir übelst drauf abgegangen.
Ja.
Warum ist der jetzt leer?
Warum ist...
Ja gut, das weiß ich eigentlich nicht.
Übrigens.
GoFundMe.
GoFundMe?
Wo hatte ich denn das letztens auf?
Ja, dann weiß ich nicht.
Ah, hier.
Es gibt übrigens Neuigkeiten von Semmy.
Da habe ich ja letztens ein bisschen Spenden gesammelt hier im Stream.
Und zwar Semmy wurde operiert.
Beine sind in Ordnung.
Und es gab jetzt ein neues Foto.
Semmy hat auch wieder angefangen ordentlich was zu fressen.
Weil ihr habt gesehen, der ist ziemlich dünn.
Also wer die Story nicht kennt.
Semmy wurde wahrscheinlich angefahren.
Hat Bein vorne, Bein hinten gebrochen gehabt.
Wurde dann abgegeben im Tierheim.
Und sich der Owner nicht mehr drum kümmern wollte.
Zumindest ist das meine Interpretation des Ganzen.
Er sieht auch ganz schön dünn.
Aber nachdem er operiert worden ist,
scheint jetzt alles soweit gut zu sein.
Bein ist am heilen und Semmy frisst wieder ordentlich.
Also.
Hat sich gelohnt.
Ein paar Euro da zu lassen, Leute.
So was freut mich immer.
Vielleicht, ich habe denen eine E-Mail geschrieben.
Und die war natürlich sehr happy.
Dass ich auch im Stream nochmal das gezeigt habe.
Und dazu aufgerufen habe, dass Leute sich das mal angucken.
Und vielleicht frage ich die auch mal in 6-7 Wochen,
wenn es denen wieder besser geht,
ob ich einfach mal vorbeifahren kann und Semmy besuche.
Dann mache ich mal ein kleines Video.
So 30 Sekunden poste ich das.
Mal gucken, wie es ihm geht.
Bei mir eignet es sich nicht.
Ich habe auch schon nach dem Motto überlegt,
ich hatte keine Katz, aber Semmy will raus.
Und bei mir ist draußen mit Straße und so nicht gut.
Bei mir gibt es nur abgesicherte Terrasse für die Katz.
Und semi abgesicherter Hof.
Aber für eine junge Katz ist das kein Problem, wahrscheinlich da auszubrechen.
Das ist zu gefährlich.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Fake Ryzen im Umlauf.
Der Auer.
Das sind Ryzen CPUs quasi.
AliExpress Ryzen.
Ich guck mir mal das Intro an.
Ich will einfach nur wissen, um was es da geht.
By the way, ich habe mein BIOS mittlerweile geupdatet.
Ich habe mein BIOS mittlerweile geupdatet.
Für mein 13900... 13700?
Was ist ein 13700k und 13900k?
13900k.
8700 war der davor.
Jetzt ist es ein 13... ok.
Was ist dein... Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Das sind Vögel.
Toe... Toe... ToeCat?
Nee, wie rühre ich bei dir überhaupt aus?
Was ist deine Meinung zu Toecans?
Die sehen bunt aus.
Keine Ahnung.
Was soll meine Meinung zu einer Vogelsorte sein?
Die sehen lustig aus.
So ein bisschen...
Komische Proportionen irgendwie.
Schnabel halb so groß wie der Rest.
Die sehen cool aus.
Stylischer Bird.
Das ist meine Meinung zu ToeCat.
Wie auch immer man die ausspricht.
Was ist deine Meinung?
Was ist deine Meinung zu Toecans?
Das war jetzt ein äußerst random Thema.
Gucken wir uns mal lieber an, was die Ryzen Zip Jungs machen.
Das ist ein Flyer Bird.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße,
Louis Vuitton Store,
Zahl die Kollektion bar,
Einzige was ich kann.
Ich hab mit deutschem Hip Hop nix am Hut.
Auch mit nicht deutschem Hip Hop hab ich nix am Hut.
Haftbefehl.
So, also was waren denn Ryzen Zip Jungs?
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zurück
zu einem weiteren Video.
Anfang August wurde ich bei Discord mit Bruce Lee verbunden.
Das ist ein Overclocker aus Rumänien.
Und der hat...
Ich dachte das ist der Sponsor des heutigen Videos.
Ich dachte jetzt kommt gleich dieses Video
mit freundlicher Unterstützung von Bruce Lee.
Und der hat sich auf der rumänischen Plattform OLX gekauft.
OLX könnte man vergleichen bei uns mit
entweder Facebook Marketplace oder
eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Wobei eBay Kleinanzeigen, ich sag das auch immer falsch,
ich glaube mittlerweile dürfen die sich
gar nicht mehr eBay Kleinanzeigen nennen.
Privatpersonen hauptsächlich.
Dementsprechend gibt es auch keine Garantie.
Aber macht nix, ich darf es eh nicht benutzen,
weil ich gebannt bin.
Und warum bin ich gebannt?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Und die sagen mir das auch nicht.
Die sagen nur ich soll ihrem Platt...
Marktplatz fernbleiben.
Obwohl ich da noch nie was drauf gemacht habe.
Aber ich bin gebannt.
Dort gefunden für den Preis von 300 Euro.
Neu original verpackt.
Was erstmal ein ziemlich guter Deal ist.
Aber wisst ihr wo ich nicht mehr gebannt bin?
Premiere, endlich. Seit Jahren nicht mehr.
Also seit Jahren war ich es.
Aber jetzt bin ich es nicht mehr.
MSI auf Twitter hat mich unbanned.
Von einer Weile.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht,
warum ich da 10 Jahre gebannt war.
Aber mittlerweile bin ich wieder entbannt.
Weil die CPU normalerweise in Rumänien
aktuell um die 400 Euro kostet.
Beziehungsweise vor dem Monat,
als er die CPU gekauft hat.
Er hat die CPU dann bekommen, hat sie ausgepackt,
hat sie eingebaut ins Mainboard und nichts ist passiert.
Also hat nicht gestartet.
Er hat dann die CPU genommen und hat sich...
So ungefähr war es bei mir auch.
Ich wollte mir einen Account anlegen,
der hat gesagt, die E-Mail Adresse ist schon in Benutzung.
Irgendwie sowas.
Und dann habe ich
Passwort Recovery gemacht, das ging nicht.
Und da habe ich hingeschrieben,
wie jetzt, warum?
Und dann haben die gesagt,
bitte bleiben sie unseren Marktplatz fern.
Wir werden auf weitere E-Mails nicht beantworten.
Okay, dann fickt euch.
Ich hatte eh nicht vor, bei euch was zu machen.
...geschnappt und hat auf der Rückseite
versucht, ein paar Widerstände zu checken.
Einfach nur um zu schauen, ob die CPU theoretisch noch lebt.
Das kann man machen, indem man
erstmal Ground-zu-Ground-Verbindungen misst
und viel relevanter dann auch Ground zur Kernspannung,
um so den Innenwiderstand der CPU zu messen.
Ah. Er hat aber...
Der hat fast das gleiche Messgerät wie ich.
... keinerlei Verbindung zwischen den Pads gefunden,
was schon wirklich komisch ist.
Ich habe ihm dann angeboten, mir die Sachen genauer anzuschauen.
Aber die Dinger sind alle ähnlich.
Und habe ihm die CPU abgekauft für 400 Euro,
weil damit konnte er sich einfach lokal dann von einem
wirklich seriösen Händler
einen neuen 7800X 3D kaufen.
Wir haben damit die CPU hier.
Sowas ist einfach nur möglich, weil ihr meine Videos schaut
und weil wir dementsprechend auch Sponsoren und Partner haben,
die solche Videos unterstützen.
Deswegen danke dafür.
Ey, ich habe einmal in meinem Leben Originale,
der Bauer Wärmeleitpaste gekauft.
Da habe ich...
Quasi habe ich
die CPU auch zu
0,00000001% unterstützt jetzt.
Du bist auf der Suche nach einem starken
und zuverlässigen Hostingpartner?
Dann bist du bei Hetzner genau richtig.
Als ein führender Hostingprovider mit eigenen
Hightech-Rechenzentren bietet Hetzner DSG...
Ey, und nicht nur Wärmeleitpaste,
sogar Flüssigmetall-Legierung.
Ich habe ConductorNaut
und Kryonaut mal gekauft.
Zwei Tuben für...
nicht viel Geld.
Ich habe gehört,
ich weiß nicht, ob es vom Chat war,
dass Hetzner angeblich planen würde,
jetzt auch Managed-Datenbanken demnächst anzubieten.
Managed Postgres.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das stimmt.
Vielleicht hat der Chat auch Insider-Informationen
gehabt und gespoilert.
Aber wenn das stimmt,
ist das sehr, sehr nice.
...
farbe der platine die einfach so von der nuance ein bisschen anders ist als üblicherweise sind
amd cpu ist mittlerweile besser als intel also aktuell weiß ich nicht ich bin da immer nur auf
dem aktuellen stand wenn ich mir selbst neuen rechner kaufen möchte ich würde sagen aktuell
fährst du mit amd tatsächlich besser weil intel die letzten jahre über übelst viele
fertigungsprobleme hatte und die 13 und 14 cpu generation von intel soweit probleme hatte dass
sie von haus aus viel geringere lebenszeit hatten als normal ist für die cpu wir reden hier von den
aktuellsten zwei cpu generation auch wirklich die high end cpus betroffen waren und die an der zwei
probleme einmal dass die dinger quasi ich nenne es mal rosten innen drin also spricht dass die
dass ich dann
layer in der cpu miteinander verbinden die sich nicht verbinden sollten und das nächste waren dass
die wohl eine buggy firmware drauf hatten microcode drauf hatten dass sie wohl mit zu viel spannung
angesteuert wurden und dadurch das ganze noch verschlimmbessert wurde also hat es quasi intel
cpus die instabil wurden oder gar kaputt gehen in viel viel kürzerer lebensspanne als sie
normalerweise haben und das ist was das sollte wirklich dem hersteller
wie intel auch gerade bei high end cpus wirklich nicht passieren ich habe auch so eine cpu ich habe
13.900 k ich habe letztens das bios update gemacht dagegen hätte ich schon probleme gehabt mit meiner
cpu ja also sprich hätte ich den jetzt die letzten zwei jahre super krass belastet deswegen ist es ja
auch zum ersten mal aufgetreten bei leuten die beispielsweise 3d rendering betreiben spiele
entwickeln oder rechner wirklich großteil der zeit wurde eingeschaltet ist auch viel macht dann werde
ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr zu retten gewesen
meine cpu hätte ich den scheiß ausbauen müssen neue also aktuell hätte ich keinen bock auf intel wenn
man mal rein von benchmarks ausgeht würde ich sagen und das weiß ich nicht weil ich mich mit aktuellen
benchmarks nicht beschäftigt habe wie gesagt ich gucke nur immer wie es aussieht wenn ich wenn ich
was kaufen will würde ich sagen ist amd tatsächlich ein ticken besser was gaming angeht als intel zur
zeit korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch liege aber das ist alles in einem bereich wo man sagen würde
macht jetzt nicht fett also performance technisch kann man sich beides kaufen und was mir noch mehr
aufgefallen ist wenn wir hier an der seite rein schauen normalerweise sind die ganzen kondensatoren
also wenn ich mich da ich kann es hier so sagen wenn ich mir jetzt neuen rechner kaufen würde
und jetzt nicht noch irgendwie bei meinen ja bei meiner recherche im vorfeld wo ich gucken
würde was ich mir kauf was was gravieren das anderes feststellen würde ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich um
wahrscheinlich ein amd rechner kaufen die sich hier außen befinden auch mit ein
bisschen kleber bedeckt zum vergleich habe ich hier einen 7800x3d der ist halt
geköpft ich habe keinen ungeköpften aktuell da ist xx hd xxi scopes
ist aber nicht so schlimm man kann trotzdem ziemlich gut sehen dass das hier
eher so ein bisschen grünlich ist rechts ist eher so ein bisschen bläulich ja und hier
sieht man eben ganz gut dass die sachen auf der platine normalerweise eben mit
kleber bedeckt sind ja das war ja auch der grund warum dann zum beispiel
produkte von uns die wir bei grizzly gemacht haben bei den x3d cpus nicht
mehr kompatibel waren der direct iframe zum beispiel weil wir dann hier sachen
im weg hatten wo eben der kleber ist der vorher nicht da war leuchtet ein und
das ist auf jeden fall für die x3d cpus sehr sehr untypisch ich habe noch mal
mehr amd am5 cpus geholt damit man noch mal so einen besseren überblick bekommt
und auch sieht dass es auch da unterschiede bei der platinenfarbe gibt
das heißt das wäre jetzt erst mal kein einfacher grund um zu sagen
dass es auch da unterschiede bei der platinenfarbe gibt das heißt das wäre jetzt erstmal kein einfacher grund um zu sagen
dass die cpu hier ein fake ist man sieht reisen 9000 aber der kleber leider
mit dem kleber ist schon auffällig blauer als es reisen 7000 ist also da ist
definitiv ein unterschied und da gibt es auch unterschiedliche platine aber die
cpu ist noch mal ein bisschen bläulicher als die reisen 9000 das ist wir packen
deswegen die cpu einfach mal in den sockel so wie es bruce lee auch gemacht
hat gemacht haben muss ich montiere jetzt auch da kein kühler
bruce lee hat vor allem gemacht BÄM
dieser grafik muss nicht ganz schön klax
und cool kalian
hat es ja sich als ich eben pepper oko
dodro maschinen und was mir auch gefallen ist das video ist so alt das
kennt wahrscheinlich keiner mehr als ich eben den bügel hier zugemacht
hat weil der bügel drückte auf den headsıs drückt dann die cpu den sockel
ist die Platine dünner als bei den anderen.
Und wahrscheinlich sitzt die deswegen auch ein bisschen niedriger
und der Anpressdruck in den Sockel ist geringer.
Wenn ich den normalen 7800X 3D hier in die Bügelmessschraube reinpacke...
Der Asitoni hat nicht Bäm gemacht, der hat gemacht Bäm Bäm Bäm.
Nee, Bam Bam Bam. Hat er Bam oder Bäm gemacht?
Ich weiß das schon gar nicht mehr.
Bam Bam. Der hat Bam gemacht einfach nur, oder?
Bam Bam Bam.
Dann habe ich eine Platinenstärke von ca. 1,31 mm.
Schauen wir uns die rumänische CPU an,
dann sehen wir hier eine Platinenstärke von unter einem Millimeter.
Und das ist ganz weit außerhalb der Fertigungstoleranz
und so normal niemals möglich.
Ich habe dann mal meine GIMP-Skills ausgepackt
und den 7800X 3D von Bruce Lee mit meinem originalen Heatspreader
von dem originalen 7800X 3D verglichen.
Ich habe beide von oben.
Fotografiert so gut wie möglich den gleichen Winkel
und habe dann den originalen Heatspreader ausgeschnitten und über die...
Da können wir nur froh sein, dass der Bauer
die ganzen technischen Hackerman-Sachen bei sich daheim hat.
Oder im Büro, in der Werkstatt.
...CPU von Bruce Lee gepackt.
So kann ich jetzt mit der Deckkraft beide übereinanderlegen
und teilweise transparent machen, um die Unterschiede einfach zu sehen.
Schon beim ersten Mal habe ich direkt Unterschiede gesehen.
Also sowohl bei der Form des Heatspreaders...
Ja, und auch bei den Logos und sowas.
Beim Heatspreader sehen wir zum Beispiel diesen oberen, dünneren Arm vom Heatspreader.
Der hat eine ganz andere Dicke.
Und bei der CPU von Bruce Lee ist es einfach viel, viel dünner.
Man muss sich an so einer Stelle dann auch erstmal immer fragen,
wie plausibel es wäre, dass es unterschiedliche Versionen von dem Heatspreader gibt.
Ich habe mal eine Frage, Chad.
Ich versuche mir gerade einen Reim drauf zu machen.
Was ist der Hintergrund von gefakten CPUs?
Weil die Dinger funktionieren ja nicht, oder?
Es ist nicht so, dass da jetzt einfach irgendwie...
eine Ur-Uralt-CPU drin steckt, die so aussieht wie eine neuere.
Das ist nicht wie diese GTX 4090 von AliExpress,
die dann eine uralte 1050 sind oder sowas.
Die Dinger gehen ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Und da ist die Frage, was hat man...
Also der einzige Grund kann ja nur sein,
sagen wir mal, Scam in Form von...
Man verkauft das jemand und ist dann über alle Berge.
Wenn der feststellt, dass sie nicht geht.
Ich persönlich halte das für äußerst unwahrscheinlich,
weil alle anderen CPUs, die ich hier habe, die ich getestet habe,
auch zum Beispiel ein 8700G,
hat zumindest mal äußerlich die gleiche Form wie jetzt ein Ryzen 7000 oder Ryzen 9000.
Weil es ist alles der gleiche Sockel und AMD würde versuchen, das zu vermeiden,
da irgendwelche Änderungen zu machen,
weil das dann immer theoretisch Einschnitte in der Kompatibilität von...
Stimmt. Ja, habe ich vergessen, Chad.
Das war ja quasi...
Das war ja quasi über so eine Art Kleinanzeigen.
Ja, okay, dann...
Was letzte Preis?
...oder sonst was hätte.
Hier sehen wir aber definitiv, dass die äußere Form unterschiedlich ist.
Was letzte Preis? Ich schicke meinen Cousin vorbei.
Der ist dumm, der macht das.
Aber auch eben die Aufschrift auf dem Heatspreader selbst.
Wenn wir erstmal das AMD Ryzen Logo oben anschauen,
sehe ich von der Form her keinen Unterschied zum Original.
Aber die Position ist an einer leicht anderen Stelle.
Schauen wir auf das Logo AMD Ryzen 7 7800X 3D,
dann ist es nicht nur anders.
Es ist nicht nur an einer anderen Stelle,
sondern auch beim ersten Hinschauen ein bisschen anders.
Also die Schriftart ist anders und die ist vor allem auch länger.
Und gerade sowas würde AMD auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Nee, das sind ja...
Du brauchst ja unterschiedliche Maschinen und so dafür.
Warum? Das macht ja...
Weil man hier intern sicherlich irgendwelche Vorschriften hat,
die sich alle halten müssen.
Aber hier sieht man zum Beispiel, dass das R, das Y und das E
in der Schrift unterschiedlich sind.
Ja.
Und das macht es schon sehr plausibel, dass das hier vielleicht ein Fake ist.
Die CPU funktioniert so auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und wir sehen leichte Unterschiede.
Was mich jetzt natürlich interessiert, was ist da unter dem Heatspadder?
Oder ist überhaupt was drunter?
Ja, das interessiert mich auch.
Ich habe dann auch wohl nochmal kurz gegoogelt.
Was hat er eigentlich da für ein nices Terrarium?
Um zu sehen, ob es schon ähnliche Fälle online dokumentiert gab.
Und ich habe zu Fake 7800X 3D nicht so wirklich was gefunden.
Es gibt einen Fall, aber da ist die CPU eine AM4 CPU, die neu gelasert wurde.
Und da sieht man ja, die CPU ist nicht so gut.
Und da sieht man ja, direkt ein Unterschied.
Der Heatspadder sieht ja ganz anders aus als bei AM5.
Da war das obvious.
Und das scheint erstmal so noch nicht dokumentiert worden zu sein.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da drunter ist.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Ist überhaupt was drunter?
Ich kann mich nicht entscheiden.
Es ist an der Stelle, wo die eigentliche CPU sitzt.
Weil das, was man hier sieht, ist ja nicht die CPU.
Die CPU ist ja immer in der Mitte dieses, das da.
Das hier ist dann quasi das hier.
Quasi die CPU.
Wahrscheinlich ist da gar nichts drunter.
Vermutlich, ich denke auch, da ist wahrscheinlich gar nichts drunter.
Da sind vielleicht noch ein paar, ja, Widerstände und Zeug und Sachen.
Aber die eigentlichen CPUs, die sind wahrscheinlich leer.
Oder man hat dort einfach irgendwelche Kästchen drauf gelötet,
die vielleicht ein bisschen so aussehen wie die eigentlichen CPU-Kerne.
Dann köpfen wir uns einfach mal die CPUs.
So quasi so eine Fake-CPU.
Dann werden wir schlauer sein.
Oder irgendeine ganz alte.
Das kann natürlich auch sein, dass es einfach auf den ersten Blick so aussieht, wie da ist ja was drauf.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt, was da drunter ist.
Also das ist schon mal untypisch.
Es hat sich direkt sehr einfach angefühlt.
Es lässt sich easy lösen, ja.
Normalerweise muss ich ja 50 mal hin und her schieben.
Also das ist nicht normal.
Wie gesagt, normalerweise ist die CPU verlötet und dann würde ich jetzt hier 10 Minuten sitzen.
Und es wird komische Geräusche machen, wo du jedes Mal denkst,
Ha, okay, nix.
Nix.
Das ist schon wirklich, wirklich lustig.
Ich hatte seitlich erst unter die CPU drunter geschaut.
Also wenn man hier ja auch drunter schaut bei einer normalen Ryzen-CPU,
dann kann man ja so ein bisschen den Chip sehen.
Und das hatte ich bei der CPU auch gemacht.
Da dachte ich mir so, hey, also da ist ja was drunter.
Die haben einfach den Heatspreader ein bisschen tiefer gebaut.
Ich muss den Kleber gleich mal abkratzen, aber das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Haben die da wirklich den Iodide und den Chip hingefärbt?
Ja.
Die haben den quasi da dran rausgeschnitten, ja.
Als Teil des Heatspreaders?
Ja, sieht so aus.
Und dann einfach nur Kleber drauf?
Also hier, das scheint mir eine leere Platine zu sein.
Aber die haben sich auch tatsächlich die Mühe gemacht, die ganzen Kondensatoren dahin zu machen.
Das ist ja komplett verrückt.
An der Stelle ist mir gerade eingefallen, dass die CPU ja auch mit einer originalen Box kam.
Und hier oben ist die Seriennummer von der CPU drauf.
Also das ist das, was hier unten steht.
Und das hatte ich auch gecheckt, weil da dachte ich so, okay, wenn das Fake ist, wie weit würde man gehen?
Aber die dritte Linie, die hier draufsteht, ist tatsächlich auch die Seriennummer, die hier auf der Box draufsteht.
Also es ist wirklich, wirklich krass professionell gemacht.
Ja, geil.
Schauen wir uns jetzt mal den Kleber hier runter und gucken uns das mal an.
Das ist einfach Metall, ja.
Ist wirklich krass, welchen Aufwand die sich gemacht haben.
Ja.
Also dass man das so macht, dass das wirklich die Chips abbildet von der Form.
Geil.
Hier die Löcher drin habe ich mich kurz gefragt.
Ich würde vermuten, weil das Vernickeln wird deutlich einfacher, wenn man irgendwo eine Schraube reindrehen kann.
Also ich vermute, das hat man deswegen gemacht für die Fake-Fertigung.
Aber so insgesamt hat sich da jemand wirklich Gedanken gemacht.
Guck mal noch das Gleiche bei der Platine an.
Ich vermute einfach mal, dass die leer ist, dass da gar nichts drauf ist.
Wenn man jetzt auch mal den Fake Heat Spreader mit einem Original vergleicht, dann sieht man beim Original,
dass hier unten in dem Bereich, da sind immer so ein bisschen Spuren.
Und das ist vom Herstellungsprozess.
Weil das wahrscheinlich Laser geschnitten und dann gestanzt ist oder nur gestanzt und das so eine Abbruchkante ist.
Und die fehlt auf dem Heat Spreader hier.
Was ich daran wirklich erschreckend finde, ist wie nah die Platine an dem Original dran ist.
Also wenn man jetzt mal von den fehlenden Chips absieht.
Also das macht keiner daheim mit einem Lötkolben in der Masse.
Die Position von den Kondensatoren zum Beispiel.
Das haben die perfekt getroffen.
Also da sind halt auch nicht alle bestückt.
Das haben die auch genau so gemacht, wie es Original ist.
Es ist aber definitiv keine Original Platine.
Also man könnte jetzt auf die Idee kommen, hat irgendjemand von AMD Platinen abgezwackt oder sowas.
Wir wissen ja, dass die Platine von der Höhe her anders ist.
Und es ist definitiv ein komplett anderes Ding und wird wahrscheinlich auch einfach gar keine Leiterbahn und nichts drauf haben.
Einfach nur hinten die Pads drauf, vorne die Kondensatoren, damit es auf den ersten Blick so aussieht, als wäre das halt eine Original CPU.
Das mit dem Heatspreader finde ich auch wirklich crazy.
Dass man sich da auch wirklich die Mühe gemacht hat, dass wenn man von der Seite reinschaut, dass man denkt, da ist ja ein Chip drunter.
Also eine richtige Fake-CPU wird das schon nicht sein.
Also da ging wirklich einiges an Aufwand rein.
Auch wie gut der Heatspreader gemacht ist.
Also mal abgesehen von der Kante, die man eben nicht sieht.
Optisch von dem Finish außen ist der Fake besser als das Original.
Also hier sind diese Fertigungsspuren nicht drauf.
Das ist wirklich krass.
Welchen Aufwand sich hier jemand gemacht hat, um das zu faken.
Das hat keiner alleine mal in einer Nacht-und-Nebel-Aktion gemacht.
Das ist wirklich extrem professionell gemacht.
Und ich würde mal schätzen, dass man da auch mehr als einen gemacht hat.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, wen man am Ende damit scammen wollte.
Sind es Endkunden, wo man die CPU online verkauft?
Oder ist es vielleicht auch AMD selber, dass man dann überlegt, okay, der Kunde schickt dann die CPU zu AMD zurück.
Aha.
AMD checkt dann die CPU und schickt dem Kunden eine neue.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie das laufen würde, wenn man so eine CPU zu AMD schicken würde.
Ja, AMD wird die sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht genau angucken, oder?
Ich meine, erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer an den Typ, der immer nur Sand zurückgeschickt hat an Amazon?
Es gab noch mal ein bisschen News vor einer ganzen Weile.
Irgendein Typ hat immer an Amazon die Pakete zurückgeschickt.
Hat gesagt, ah, brauche ich nicht mehr und wollte das Geld wieder haben.
Und der hat einfach nur Sand reingefüllt.
In die Pakete.
Dass das Paket das gleiche gewogen hat wie vorher.
Weil Amazon nie den Inhalt kontrolliert hat.
Amazon hat das Paket gekriegt, hat das Paket gewogen.
Und wenn das Plus Minus das gleiche gewogen hat, wie als es rausgegangen ist, wurde es einfach direkt in den Müll geschmissen.
Und er kam da wohl eine Weile mit durch.
Auf jeden Fall mega interessant und zeigt, wie vorsichtig man sein muss.
Dieses Problem wird man mit Sicherheit nicht haben,
wenn man von vertrauensvollen Händlern kauft.
Also egal, welchen deutschen Händler ihr nehmt.
Da hättet ihr ja immer den Schutz, dass, wenn ihr so ein Fake bekommen würdet,
dann könntet ihr den Händler kontaktieren und könntet sagen, ey, das ist keine echte CPU.
Dann könnte er auch nachverfolgen, woher er es hat.
Könnte vielleicht rechtliche Konsequenzen daraus ziehen.
Und ihr würdet wahrscheinlich einfach eine neue CPU bekommen.
Wir haben bei uns in einem Büro, fällt mir gerade so ein,
gibt bei uns auf der Arbeit so einen Erholungsbüro-Raum.
Da hängen auch so Moos-Dinger an der Wand.
Und da steht ganz groß dran, Achtung, so kein Kunst-Moos, bitte nicht anfassen.
Und dreimal dürft ihr raten, was das erste ist, was jeder macht,
wenn er zum ersten Mal in dieses Büro reinkommt.
Erstmal seinen Finger in dieses Moos reinstecken.
Wenn ihr das normal kauft, halte ich das für relativ unwahrscheinlich und unproblematisch,
dass man jetzt da sagt, oh, großes Risiko, Fake-AMD-CPUs im Umlauf.
Für den normalen Kunden wird es wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich relevant sein.
Außer man ist viel auf Schnäppchen-Jagd, vielleicht wie auch Bruce Lee das war.
Und man denkt, ich kaufe kein Anzeigen oder sowas was.
Da könnte man dann eben auf die Schnauze fallen.
Und wirklich krass. Also sowas so gut gemacht vor allem,
habe ich echt noch nicht gesehen.
Hätte man die Platine noch dicker gemacht,
so ein bisschen näher am Original dran, dann würde das wirklich, wirklich schwer auffallen.
Das mit dem Kleber an der Seite auf den Kondensatoren haben die wahrscheinlich weggelassen,
weil das auch sehr schwer zu faken ist.
Und das ist halt nichts, was ein 0815 Platinenhersteller dir auch als Service anbietet
und sagt so, ey, ich mache jetzt hier automatisiert einen Kleber, der aufgetragen wird.
Da muss man dann schon echt eine gute Stückzahl bei einem Platinenhersteller anfragen,
um so einen Service auch zu bekommen.
Ansonsten gibt es halt das normale, konforme Coating, um eine Platine zu schützen.
Das gibt es relativ häufig. Das sieht dann aber anders aus
und würde man dann wahrscheinlich auf den ersten Blick auch direkt sehen.
Deswegen haben sie das wahrscheinlich weggelassen.
Aber vorsichtig sein.
Weil der Schnäppchen jagt bei so Online-Portalen.
Was ich vergessen habe, natürlich kann es auch sein, dass die typischen Handels...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, es gibt eine Regel, die bewahrheitet sich öfters, als dass man verkehrt liegt.
Und zwar, wenn etwas zu gut aussieht, um wahr zu sein, dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht wahr.
Und das trifft bei ganz vielen Sachen zu.
Zum Beispiel bei den Handelsplätzen, AliExpress, Temu und so weiter.
Wish ist nicht mehr angesagt, oder?
Sollen, weil natürlich das dann aus dem chinesischen Raum in die ganze Welt getragen wird
und das für alle in der anderen restlichen Welt dann in der Regel unmöglich ist,
den Verkäufer auch rechtlich zu verfolgen und irgendwie sein Geld wieder zu bekommen.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Generell seid einfach vorsichtig, wenn ihr solche Online-Käufe macht und wer immer...
Also ich hatte noch nie irgendwie das Verlangen, eine High-End-CPU über eBay kleiner zu kaufen.
Daniel sehe ich genauso. Mein Gedanke.
Ich würde mir im Leben nicht eine CPU für 400, 500 Euro bei Temu, Wish oder AliExpress oder gar eBay kleiner kaufen.
Amazon? Ja.
Also Amazon würde ich das kaufen, bei Amazon musst du halt gucken, ist es Amazon direkt oder ist es ein Shop und was ist es für ein Shop, der dahinter steht.
Ich bin...
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass auch der ein oder andere Scam über Amazon Marketplace läuft.
Also wo du safe bist, ist, wenn du dir das halt bei, keine Ahnung, Mindfactory, Alternate oder so kaufst.
Dann bist du safe.
Und so lange es direkt von Amazon kommt, meiner Meinung nach auch.
Ich hab... Also meinen letzten PC, den hier, den habe ich bei drei verschiedenen...
Ich glaube, den habe ich bei drei verschiedenen Jobs... Shops bestellt.
Die Grafikkarte habe ich, glaube ich, bei Amazon bestellt.
Das Netzteil und Dings. Ein paar Sachen habe ich bei Mindfactory bestellt.
Die SSD habe ich auch bei Amazon bestellt. Die SSD und die Festplatte.
Die CPU. Ich habe bei drei verschiedenen Shops, musste ich das hier bestellen, weil nicht alle die Sachen lieferbar hatten.
So sieht es aus.
Doch, das sieht man. Das steht immer dran bei Amazon, ob du direkt bei Amazon kaufst.
Da steht immer Verkauf und Versand von Amazon.
Dann weißt du, das stimmt.
Das ist von Amazon und wenn das ein Marketplace-Typ ist, dann steht das da.
Ja, das Geld ist zusammengekommen. Ich hab's doch... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Schön, dass du fragst.
Das Geld ist zusammengekommen.
Und es gibt auch neue Updates.
Sammy wurde mittlerweile operiert.
Und die Beine sind am heilen und Sammy futtert auch schon wieder was.
Gab's erst gestern oder so ein Update mit diesem neuen Bild.
Dass der wieder...
Also Geld ist zusammengekommen.
Also schön, dass ihr mitgemacht habt.
Wer mitgemacht hat, auch immer mitgemacht hat, weiß ich ja nicht.
Und Sammy geht's wieder besser.
Aber dauert jetzt natürlich noch sechs, sieben Wochen, bis alles wieder verheilt ist.
Er ist ziemlich dünn gerade.
Danach ist er hoffentlich wieder ein bisschen dicker.
Sieht normaler aus.
So, Arch by the way.
Neue Package-Updates.
Nein.
Okay.
Ich mein, das ist erst eine Stunde her, wo ich Package-Updates gemacht hab.
Man weiß ja nie.
Yep.
Okay, Leute.
Heute ein bisschen kürzerer Stream.
Wie gesagt, ich bin gestern drei Stunden Fahrrad gefahren.
Und seitdem tut mir ein bisschen der Rücken weh.
Und hab auch ein bisschen Kopfweh.
Bleib jetzt mal nicht direkt nach dem Aufstehen ein paar Stunden vorm Rechner hocken.
Sondern ich leg mich jetzt nochmal kurz hin.
Dann ess ich was.
Und dann lauf ich mal eine Runde draußen rum.
Und so, dass das alles wieder besser wird.
Wir hören uns.
Gut.
See you.
Mit Java kenn ich mich nicht aus, ne.